the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
dogfight at the U.S women's and U.S open
championships in St Louis elite players
continue to take our breath away with
their daring play it's blue skies for
Maverick Fabiano caruana who play
dangerously but outgunned a spiraling
elshon moradia body to solidify his top
spot in the standings Irena Crush has
caught fire and is coming in hot winning
her third straight game stealing Talia
Cervantes acoustic to cruise into a tie
for first place the leaders are flying
high will they continue to climb or will
they crash and burn day seven of
adrenaline fuel Gest coming up next
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day 7 of the
2022 us chess championships and U.S
women's chess championships behind me is
a plane belonging to the U.S Navy's Blue
Angels who are famous for their
Precision formation flying well we're
definitely going to be looking for some
precise moves over the chessboard as
well let's go to the studio and start
the action with Yasser and Anastasia
[Music]
from the home of Chess in the United
States welcome to the Saint Louis chess
club and the seventh round of the yes
chess championships and the U.S women's
chess championships
[Music]
I'm Anastasia Carlos hello everyone and
I'm here joined by my great Grandmaster
co-host Yasser ceravan awesome Anastasia
as well yes sir we are already on the
round seven six rounds are already in
the history of United States Chess and
it's been really really exciting half
what do you think about it well
Anastasia if the second half is anything
like the first it's going to be all fun
and games I tell you it was great hello
everyone and thank you for joining our
show
round six featured something really
extraordinary I'm not used to seeing it
six out of the seven games that were
decisive were won by the black pieces
White had been dominating right up until
yesterday what will round seven ring
well we're about to find out Anastasia
who are our leaders let's start with the
ladies let's check the leaders and we
have actually two of them because uh
Arena Crush just joined Jennifer you on
the leads yesterday she won the game and
both of them have four and half points
Alias Lee megably they have four points
that share the third place and then we
have tarati of Abraham on the fifth
place and beg him with
um
both of them are profiled for the sixth
place with 50 and in the open section
what about our leaderboard there
managed to increase his lead to one
point he is on the first place with four
and half points and then we have Ray
Robson and Sam save and they share the
second place together also with a Wonder
Liang and then Wesley solely near
Dominguez drunk all of them have 50
trailing pack and our formats for our
two national championships and the
format we have 14 players in each
tournament it's round robin event every
everyone will play with everyone and
then we have 90 minutes for the first 40
moves followed by 30 minutes for the
rest of the games and then 30 seconds
increment from move one another offers
fighting until the end you mentioned the
schedule we're almost halfway through
what's our remaining schedule look like
so we have four rounds until we have the
second rest day which will come on
October 16th then three rounds more and
then playoffs if needed on October 20s
great I see that we got more details uh
coming in about the closing ceremonies
let's have a peek at what they are so
everybody can actually visit the closing
ceremony you just need to buy the ticket
25 dollars per person a bargain yeah and
then we have so many things to do 6 p.m
cocktail party and then we have a
boarding ceremony itself at 7 pm and
then after party with DJ sounds great
yes sir absolutely are you ready to
dance yes looking forward to it and and
Christian uh you're with us today good
to see you my friend tell us about the
challenges laying ahead for our
tournament leaders great uh to see you
guys great to be back in the studio as
we enter the second half of the event
the two championships are heating up and
let's take a look at the road ahead of
our leaders we're going to start with
the open section well this is a one-man
show up to this point and it's that man
Grandmaster Fabiano caruana today he
will be facing with the white pieces
Alexander Linderman actually yeah last
year when he needed a victory with the
black pieces managed to outplay
Alexander landerman and that was a
crucial victory maybe he can pull a
victory as well he will definitely try
today because he also has the white
pieces tomorrow in round 8 against Sam
Savion with the black pieces in round
number nine with the white pieces
against Liang and in round 10 against
the 15 year old teenager Christopher you
also with the black pieces and let's
take a look at where these four players
are in the standings right now we see
Sam sevilleon and a Wonder Liang tied
for second position one point behind
Fabiano caruana Alex Slenderman and
Christopher you are tied for the fifth
position and actually Christopher you
has had so many decisive results in this
tournament and that one in particular
that Victory with the black pieces
against Wesley so all of these four
games are going to be extremely tough
for our leader and let's take a look at
what we have in the ladies section the
road ahead for one of our co-leaders
grand master I will not crushed the
a-time national champion today with the
black pieces she will be facing Rue Yang
yen in round 8 Sophie Mauri Suzuki round
nine against the youngest competitor in
the field Alice Lee only 12 years of age
with the black pieces and a big clash
with Rochelle Wu in round 10 and where
do these ladies stand right now in the
standings we see Alice Lee has been
having a fantastic event so far this is
her first U.S chess championships and
she's definitely proving that she
deserves to be here Rue Yang Yan tied
for the sixth position in the middle of
the pack Rochelle Wu tied for the eighth
position and Sophie Mori Suzuki tied for
the 12th position struggling up to this
point and we do have another co-leaderer
player that we have been talking about
quite a lot and actually I highlighted
her yesterday during uh the open of the
show that is woman Grand Master Jennifer
you who has been impressing so far far
in the event today she will be facing
with the black pieces Megan Lee that one
is a big Clash round date against her
good friend Rochelle Wu round nine
against the swaron and round 10 against
the two-time national champion Nazi
paikidze needless to say she has a very
tough road ahead especially today that
game against Megan Lee who has been
impressing so far we remember that game
against Irina Crush Where She defended
valiantly in a very difficult position
ashwita swaran well she's warming up
back-to-back victories after a slow
start and Rhino tied for eight position
Rochelle will also tied for this eighth
position and tied for the 12th position
definitely not having a great event is
Nazi Pai Pizza Guys needless to say we
have so many amazing games and so many
combative rounds ahead of us at the U.S
championships wow well thank you for
that Christian as we see you players who
have gotten through the security check
uh time for the coffee break there as 28
competitors the security checks have
been very I want to say thorough
thorough as uh we have our fair play
rules here at the St Louis chess club
and uh Anastasia please do the honors
tell our audience what they can expect
for all the pairings let's start with
the ladies let's check the ladies we
just saw Jennifer you yes on the screens
and she plays against Megan Lee that
will be our Marquee matchup absolutely
for sure look at all the points that are
between those two competitors and then
begin will play with her friend Tatum
and it's going to be a really
interesting fight between two friends
but still have to fight over the board
absolutely we have Irina craft playing
with latissis against
and also aliasley will play against
Rochelle Wu and in the Open Pairings
what can we expect there what are the
classes I'm wondering who is the
stronger Sam Shanklin or Sam Sabian it's
going to be a big fight between Sam with
the real Sam step forward right and
Fabiano Caron will play against Alex
Linderman Ray Robson will play against
the Wesley so a big Clash of Titans
there absolutely and then we'll also
look forward to check the game Jeffrey's
song Drunk against a Wonder yeah
absolutely uh there we say Lanier
Dominguez adjusting the white pieces now
what he is doing is just making sure
that each and every piece is centered on
the Square and it's a habit that I
picked up almost from the time that I
started playing chess I wanted my pieces
to always be on the center of the square
did you do the same thing yeah I also
like this like order and it's nice to
see actually Wesley so in a good mood
chatting with Leonard you can hear them
laughing it's great to be in a good mood
before they're out the two types of
players those players who adjust the
night so that they're facing the
opponent and then the other players are
the players who twist their Knights head
so they're looking sideways what about
yourself I think I like when they look
forward yeah so ready to jump yeah
yes yes absolutely yes we hear uh the
bell sound
um in starting uh round seven and there
we see uh Megan Lee one E4
and E5 by Jennifer and of course these
players will be fighting for three weeks
uh for the national championship titles
but beside that a lot of money uh comes
uh with their success let's start with
the ladies what are they fighting for
exactly
160 thousand and 500 huge price funds
and the first place will get 40
something the winner the champion will
get 40 and then 30 and 20 for the second
and third place all the way to 14th
Place and the last one place even get
three thousand really decent price very
nice and in the open section what are
they fighting for there and in the open
section uh players are fighting for 262
000 price fund 60 for the winner the
champion of America and then 45 for the
second place and 35 for the third one
very very handsome price uh funds indeed
thank you to the St Louis chess club and
Scholastic Center not only for putting
on a magnificent event but also for the
great prizes that the players are
fighting for the battle of the two Sands
exactly and as we see in Berlin with
castles we're sure to see Knight takes
E4 and as round seven gets underway any
surprises for you so far Christian just
checking the action no no absolutely not
well first of all the action right now
is not waiting it's not updating For Me
Maybe it updates for you or not yeah sir
but as standings go I have to say I'm
not impressed by the fact not
necessarily impressed but not surprised
by Fabiano caruana's lead as of right
now in my opinion he definitely came
into uh this tournament with a chip on
his shoulder he's been having a lot of
rough events in the last couple of uh
months with the Olympia as well as the
candidates so I was definitely looking
at what he will bring to the table and
he's definitely showing a different
Fabiano and this one and of course in
the ladies section we know Irina Crush
she can definitely win games on command
and uh of course Jennifer iyushi
impressed us as well during the U.S
Juniors uh we were calling the action
for that one as well we were expecting
that she will bring her A-game in this
one also absolutely as we were coming in
our broadcast to Christian you were
mentioning that for Fabi he would like
to press his luck today that is to say
he he won he just won with the black
pieces against elshon today he's playing
the white pieces against the lower rated
Alexander Lindemann and he's feeling it
he really wants to uh well hey while the
iron is hot right if it's not broken
don't fix it yeah right you're winning
games you might as well continue winning
games and extending your lead and this
is exactly what I think his mindset will
be going into this event and we can see
already a very aggressive stance by 5
Aviano we he played this move Queen to
C2 and after d takes C4 not the usual
Queen takes C4 but rather E4 that's an
interesting wrinkle I have to say
definitely a Twist I'm not used to just
looking at this I mean
[Laughter]
it's kind of funny sometimes you know
you just you just think about a move
like E4 exactly at this moment so Queen
to C2 D takes T4 I probably suspect in
the database there are 10 000 games no
less yes you're right yes not not ten
thousand games one one thousand eight
hundred with Queen takes C4 right
automatically yes and only 200 with E4
right I mean I've had this position on
multiple occasions as white and really I
I mean I was like uh blinded I didn't
see any of the move beside Queen takes
C4 exactly in fact the move e to E4 just
it's a decent move it just somehow right
I mean I was always thinking that I'm
playing Queen C2 in order to recapture
with the queen and uh the move E2 E4 uh
as uh Christians Christian Christian
just mentioned while it's been played
before uh it's very very rare compared
to queen Tech C4 what is it about the
move E2 E4 that you think attracted Fabi
well what attracted him is the fact that
he actually faced it against firuja in
2020 if you ruja played this against him
so he gave him some ideas it's
incredible and quite impressive to see
how these players whenever they play a
game they take notes oh you play this
against me it means that you probably
looked at it and it's probably playable
so I might as well try it myself as well
this is exactly what we're seeing right
now from Fabiano and by the way I have
to say seeing Linderman think as early
as move five we know he is a theoretical
wizard I have to say Alexander Letterman
he always knows what he's doing in the
opening phase of the game especially if
we remember this tournament against
Christopher you with the white pieces he
had such an amazing opening preparation
and he displayed the move B5 he did not
expect this idea with E4 and right now
he will have to figure things out over
the chessboard without any prior
extensive knowledge I'm sure he knows
some ideas but he doesn't have the
extensive knowledge that we know Fabiano
has he looks puzzled a little bit right
and he played B5 move and he took off
his mask because he wants to leave
so B7 B5 uh a move I certainly uh has my
uh full stamp of approval uh simply
defending the pawn the one thing that I
might
quiz about the moves Queen C2 followed
by E4 is the fact the pawn on D4 is a
little bit less protected with the queen
on D1 of course if you could play Bishop
takes C4 you're happy so one move I
would definitely consider uh is the move
Bishop G4 after all if I eliminate this
Knight I can then pick up a second pawn
and if you have to play Just for
argument's sake a move like Bishop E3 it
does have the consequence that you would
allow me to double the pawns on F3 but
the move b7b B5 sure looks like a legit
move you're going to play the slav
defense well b7b side B5 is part and
parcel white B3 he just survived and
immediately B3 uh they're still
following the game of hirosha versus
carvana right I was about to say that
there are two approaches that white can
make and there's these types of
positions one is to play A2 A4 with the
idea that we can B5 and then follow it
up with B3 or to start with B3 and then
just go for a straight Pawn sacrifice
with C4 takes B3 A3 A2 it takes B3 and
what happened in that pawn Sacrifice
game then what uh what was it that uh
that that Fabi found uh he didn't like
for white for black so this is how that
game continued um by the way at this
point you have a couple of moves E6 is
by far uh the most played G6 is also an
option try the develop the bishop and
fiance on a G7 after the move E6 which
Fabiano played Bishop to D3 was
firusha's response a very natural
response that is and Fabiano went with
Bishop to B7 castle and Bishop to E7
very natural display of development in a
position don't waste any time by playing
A5 just get your pieces out as fast as
possible and try to play for the very
typical break C5 this is what black is
trying to do Castle 97 A6 potentially
reinforcing uh the support of the Pawn
on B5 and then played the move C5 if you
manage to get the move C5 in a good
setup then your position is going to be
perfectly fine now what you have to
worry right now is of course the pawn on
B5 and this is how the game continued
Rook 2 D1 was played and I'm quite
curious to see where Fabiano's novelty
lies in this game because it's going to
be very interesting it's very natural
for Alex to continue and play these
moves Bishop to B7 and Bishop to E7 so
I'm expecting something something
similar to that we're going to have to
wait and see where Fabiano is going to
come up with an improvement because he
surely will and I'm looking at the
engine of eval as well and it's about
equal about equal maybe giving white a
little bit of an edge nevertheless it's
all about how much you've studied this
position in anticipation of this game
how much knowledge do you have about the
position because if you make a bad move
if you make the wrong move instead of A5
maybe Knight to D7
plus 0.5 right right that's a pretty
decent Advantage right I go Knight to C3
now the engine is thinking a little bit
more plus 0.60 0.8 so there's definitely
pitfalls in the position my
understanding is that at the right
moment white is going to go E5 kick the
Knight away get the Knight to E4 and
we're going to see an attack coming on
at the king side against the king that
is going to most likely Castle I'm ready
for it I have my queen on C2 my
bishopone D3 once I open up this
diagonal you will uh have to deal with a
lot of pressure on the pawn on H7 so
there's still some time left before
black finishes is development and white
is going to try to take advantage of
that extra time that he has to arrange
their pieces on the best squares at the
cost of a pawn right and there aren't
that many targets and lenders
lenderman's position so that's going to
be very interesting let's turn our
attention to the ladies game
as white this will take you down memory
lane Christian as Arena crash who has
quite a number quite a variety I want to
say of Sicilians in her repertoire she's
also noted uh as a classical
sicilianist with the move d76 today went
right down the uh line the main lines
and this was played in the world
championship match between Magnus
Carlson and Fabiano now this is a uh I
want to say a really well-known uh
position and I remember uh back in the
70s and 80s there was this really tricky
move order that white uh sometimes
played with the move uh c2c3 which trust
me takes you down a real real rabbit
hole but a2a4 was a novelty that Fabi uh
played I think well the team yeah speak
on behalf of the team who came up with
a2a4 I don't think A4 was a novelty oh
A4 A4 was definitely not a novelty
um I don't remember exactly who came
with this idea but we were looking at
this variation for weeks pretty much
yeah since the match started and we
understood that Magnus is most likely
going to go with the reshnikov in pretty
much all his games we started looking
for ideas and we came up with a lot of
ideas finally we landed on this Knight
to D5 and of course we all broke our
necks analyzing this position and trying
to understand where his ideas lie where
magnus's ideas lie and it's a very
volatile position I have to say black it
doesn't look like it's doing much right
now but very easily he can play moves
such as G5 follow it up with F4 and he's
very ready to open things up on the king
side of course white is enjoying for the
moment a nice space advantage on the
queen side and of course you're enjoying
some weaknesses that you want to work
with the pawn on A5 potentially C3
followed by B4 is an idea as well try to
kick the Knight away from a C5 that
Knight is most likely going to land in
the center it's a very very volatile uh
position and I have to say whoever once
again knows better the middle game
because it's all about about the middle
game we were seeing a lot of positions
when we were analyzing this Knight to D5
in which black was sacrificing one two
pawns and it didn't seem like he has a
lot of compensation but as we were going
through the lies we understood it's
actually long-term compensation that
attack on the king side is going to come
very quickly and uh White will have to
be very precise in order to keep that at
Bay so it's not an easy position for
either side yeah so I think it's
actually a good choice by Arena Crush
against her young opponent right to to
have this complicated position where
most probably should simply knows more
oh yes yes but I like the theory let's
take a look at the practice one I'm
seeing one hour 32 for ruin and I'm
seeing 1 hour 32 for uh Arena Crush as
well which means both ladies came like
very very well prepared indeed and
what's the latest and greatest on this
position how do is white bear in this
line well right now there is a big
threat okay position you have to address
that as uh black what is the threat B4
and you don't want to allow B4 just yet
you want to make white work for it
because after B4 you take them before
you take on B4 the pawn on A4 is
actually protected by both the queen and
the Rook so I have two protectors what
you should do as black is Bishop to D7
my Spidey Sense just jumped okay yes yes
you can take on D6 and I can take back
with ambition and you can take back and
then I can take on A4 right and then we
go into those type of uh tactical melees
and Bishop D7 by the way was played oh
really 57 on the board and this is the
best move by far if you do allow white
to go B4 white is going to have an
advantage so you have to make white
labor for that expansion to see that
expansion uh successfully land on the
board
just just for fun
perhaps I can start with Bishop D6 just
to not give you any extra options yes
take take and no take on A4 right and
let's say you can take still with a rook
no I think you have to take with the
road now Europe drop by work so I've
essentially I've traded my A4 Pawn with
the D6 Bond so I have a passer which is
blockaded and maybe you have the better
minor piece your knight is strong but
I'm sure this is theoretical and uh how
do the engines evaluate this theory yes
B4 actually is just a very bad move it
has never been played yeah but we were
looking a bit sorry
yes 1966 has been paid once but it
allows black after this this bishop
takes A4 Rook takes A4 Rook to F4
um this seems to be close to equal I see
that but it doesn't seem like black has
any uh big difficulties I can just
simply go G6 maybe even Knight to E4 but
solidifying the position with G6 seems
to be the right solution right and once
again you still have this guy right to
worry about and if you do play the move
C4 guess what your Bishop becomes weaker
right yes because it's shooting uh
towards its own pawns so
and it's very difficult I have such a
nice blockading uh setup you cannot
Advance the pawns and make uh make D6 D7
and put a lot of pressure through that
expansion that's not possible so white
is actually unfortunately stuck at this
point she decided I'm actually she has
not decided yet against that but I do
believe that we're not going to see
Knight takes D6 Rook to E1 seems to be
the best move try to improve the
position even more Rook to E1 followed
by Bishop to F3 and things of that
nature maybe even Land The Rook on E6 at
times a sacrifice of course you have to
be ready for that then it's not a given
that's going to be successful but those
are the ideas that we're seeing in this
position right now all right Fantastico
by the way uh Knight takes A5 such moves
probably tactically just don't work
Knight takes A5 Rook takes it before
Bishop takes A4 I
I could have an issue all right thank
you uh Christian for that turning our
attention to our other code leader uh
Jennifer you uh the Scottish
when you don't like the Berlin and when
you don't like the Joko piano uh the
scotch yes uh comes uh in their steps I
played this line
um
as black and you can play Bishop C5 or
you can start with Queen F6 there are
actually two options here to get to the
same position for example if white would
continue here with Bishop E3 after
Bishop C5 okay you can play Queen F6
here and go to this position with C3 and
you know there is a nice streak if you
take on C6 you take only three
written in Checkmate first okay so like
if you take here 93 some white has to
react all right and then you spoil the
system
structure is not very nice uh Pond
structure for white so uh what happened
was Megan played
main alternative to Bishop E3 and C3
Bishop B6 and I I know I I studied the
games of blueberry lubemate she'd like
to throw in the move A4 A6 before
playing Knight C3 because his idea is to
pursue this bishop and that would
provoke the move in Knight E7 uh Megan
said no I'm happy with Knight c397
because she wanted to get in Bishop G5
once again in uh threatening
intermitting that she wants to play
Knight to D5 take advantage of this pin
and Jennifer said stop it
I get it go away now at first blush you
see a move like this and you go oh
that's a kind of a
ugly weakness and in truth it is but
also in truth if black castles plays D6
she would probably be reaching for her F
Pawn to attack in the center anyway just
a typical idea here you have to play F5
here right so Jennifer reasons that the
move F7 and F6 isn't bad because she's
anticipating that she'll be able to play
F5 in the very near future castles and
now A4 but now a slight difference uh
maybe black gets the option of A5 now
that the Knight is committed to the C3
Square so why is that important I don't
know if it is or if it isn't but in this
position if you start with A4 right away
what what just happened there guys I
just got a newsletter in here has left
the playing Hall Lanier has won this
game oh my God because he won oh my
goodness
check this out guys oh no attracted
this happened this might be the quickest
game ever no I know the quickest game in
U.S championship history but it's okay
go ahead take on D5 Queen takes D5 and
and Bishop takes C4 right if you take
with the queen I go rookie one your
[ __ ] 27 is hanging if you take a bit
with the bishop I go Knight C3 you
defend I pick it up I go rookie one
again I pick up the beach Pony seven you
are lost you're losing one piece right
what a situation we have here at the U.S
chess championships it's been what 15
minutes
wow oh my God oh my goodness I'll show
you the quickest game in U.S
Championship history
and we have for Lanier this is amazing
he wasn't in time trouble okay maybe he
was a little time trouble he left very
very early yeah
um oh my God let me just get in this
quick comment and then we'll recover
from the shock if you play A5 A4 A5 then
there's actually this move Knight A3 and
Knight C4 can prove a little bit awkward
let's just get to the game position as
Jennifer's played
uh pardon me Megan has just played the
move Queen D2 okay this is uh quite
stunning uh Christian from
and Chris is taking a photo of it
I mean for uh his Facebook page uh how
did it happen how did that uh game
happen it was a a Russian it's a Petrov
yeah yeah and we know that linear is
also a petrol player himself as well but
I'm I'm I'm in shock right now I have to
say D4 D5 Bishop D3 this is all very
standard uh Theory everybody knows this
bishop to E7 Bishop to F5 I think linear
has played this Fabiano caruana has
played this couple of uh times nepo has
played this countless of times as well
and yeah just Castle he forgot about uh
1966 first they take C4 first that's an
option or Knight to C6 of course
um oh my goodness yeah the xc4 seems to
be by far the computer Choice the
computer as well as the Player's Choice
with 46 games Knight to C6 only three
games and Castle only one game and after
Castle taking on D5
I mean you're just lost the pawn right
you have to save your knight with a move
Knight to D6 something along those lines
because Knight to C3 is coming and it's
coming quite quickly also Rook to E1
putting a lot of pressure on this guy
for example if you go Bishop to F6 and
try to say that yes next move I will
take on a D5 I have a couple of options
one of them being Rook to E1
now another one is to just simply defend
my Pawn with the move Queen to B3 and if
you take take on D5 take on e4 take only
four and then Knight to C3 you might
have some problems in that ensuing and
game so things are already Grim after C
takes D5 but by the way to see Queen
takes D5 and at this point elshon has
one hour and 25 minutes on his clock
linear one hour and 27 minutes
and he's probably just counting His
blessings and he's like what am I
missing right I guess this is what
elshon might have missed the fact that
you take on ic3 I take take but then I
take with a check yes that is the
problem check intermed soaking to h8 I
pick up the bishop and
and I'm sure we'll we'll chat with
Lanier and and see what he thinks of
this game well as uh as uh we get Lanier
set up I will show you the shortest game
ever played in a U.S Championship it was
between Cameron shirazi and Jack Peters
it was played in Berkeley uh berserkley
California and uh it was uh one of these
um I want to say Wing Gambit yes before
I used to play it though yes this type
of thing and let's see I think it was
10.3 A3 D5 okay and Cameron had
literally just sat down with the white
pieces as he's playing all of these
moves and he I see what's happening yes
oops and uh and it was five minutes into
the round and all of us were looking
down and uh kamran had lost but back to
you Christian and our first guest of the
day very early I must say happy birthday
earlier it's been 20 minutes since the
start of this round you came yesterday
into the studio you said that finally
you have to pick things up and start
winning games and you did just uh that
what are your initial thoughts after
this uh yeah I mean I should have fold
it I wanted to win some games but I
didn't expect
uh yeah I mean very uh well usual of
course I think I haven't won a game like
this in in 20 years or something but
this is of course a well-known trick in
this line and um okay he uh elshon
doesn't play the Petrov usually
so I figured that he prepares something
in rookie one on my bd2 here instead of
C4 which is the line that I that I
played in in a couple of games before
so I I was trying to pick a different
line so that he
would not be able to use his preparation
and just get a normal position but uh of
course there is this trick in this line
and uh when when he was sinking after C4
I uh I was very happy because I thought
that they made the right choice at least
he has to uh to think or at least to
remember some of his preparation but
when he went Castle then I suspected
that he might might have just missed
this history what was your reaction when
you saw him touching the king and going
for Castle because after taking on D5
you're already close yeah this is
already like a huge Advantage here so
yeah I mean after he was thinking when I
play C4 I I mean I wasn't expecting of
course that he would play this but uh
but I knew that somehow he would uh he
he was not that familiar with with the
position and but of course Castle was uh
was a huge surprise and then he took on
D5 daily realize at this point after
taking on D5 that his loss or uh no I
think it was after I took only four that
he he realized
um but uh yeah I mean after you play
castle is uh of course I strongly
suspected that he was going to take on
the fight because you don't play castle
in order to play an id6 or or remove did
he think about taking on D5 yeah just
for I mean maybe just 30 seconds 30
seconds yeah something like that so it
was his intention to transpose to the
main line of course but he was not sure
what's the best way and and he thought
probably that after Queen takes D5
rookie 196 it is the the line that he
wanted to play but uh but it just
doesn't work and just move order yeah
yeah absolutely linear I mean what else
can be said about the game
congratulations uh that's a huge victory
for you
um to enter the second half of the event
now since there's only 20 minutes since
the start of uh the round we're gonna
work you a little bit
let's take a look outside no free day
for you a little free day for you let's
take a look at some of the other games
that are happening right now uh Fabiano
also came with this idea Quincy to take
on uh C4 and E4 do you know anything
about this line yeah I used to play this
line I mean I used to play this laugh as
black and and I remember realizing Queen
C2 takes of course Queen takes E4 it's
the main line and then Bishop R5 for
Bishop G4 but there is this idea to play
E4 and and and Sack upon like this to
b5p3
um have you ever faced it no no I
remember uh analyzing it for for for
black at some point like maybe 15 years
ago but uh but I I don't think I got to
play line that's black
ever and now we have this position on
the board A6
things are happening quickly Knight to
C3 Castle Knight to C3 of course Castle
is not possible for uh black right now
because after E5 dropped the pawn on H7
so how should the black develop finish
the development in distribution well
usually yeah I mean night goes on D7
Bishop on B7 but this is the type of uh
Pawn sacrifice which is slightly
unpleasant for black you also get some
of those positions in the Catalan and in
some some positions of the Queen's
Gambit were uh yeah white is down upon
but a lot of space you have the center
and you have always this E5 Knight to E4
ideas the black blacks King is always a
little bit uncomfortable in in the
center or even in the king side if the
pawn gets to V5 which it will so Bishop
to B7 is on the board right now yeah and
then probably something like a rook B1
and just black steel cannot Castle
because of E5
so at some point black probably has yeah
we'll probably play some H6 but yeah
even if white goes like Bishop of four
and just play normal moves
it should be it should be quite uh quite
nice play for white I guess but of
course it's it's uh it's a game it's a
long lasting compensation yeah yeah
let's see the sequence of events that
happen in your game actually and you
take us through this situation uh wow
everybody was flabbergasted what just
happened five minutes did they agree to
a draw
[Laughter]
we see Hands in the back also our
photographers as well it seems like even
our chief Arbiter is stunned he's like
whoa this was not supposed to happen
did they want you after the game
there's no point there's no point in
checking uh
and checking me because it's uh and you
seemed a little bit distraught as as
well what were your emotions right now
no I mean I felt sorry for him because
just to lose a game like this it's just
very painful and after he he's having a
bad tournament and
um you can lose but I mean to lose like
this it's uh it's uh
it's not nice at all so I yeah I I saw
he was really sad but yeah it happens
sometimes yeah absolutely this is a
comparative Sports and these things do
happen guys any questions before we let
Lanier go no just uh I want to Echo your
exact thoughts as well linear that it's
been 20 years since I won a game in an
opening trap at this level of the
national championship this was quite a
gift and go enjoy yourself
yes congratulations yes it was expected
but really nice Victory sometimes it
happens exactly uh just going around the
uh the boards for a moment I'm looking
at the game between Talia and Anna both
uh Italia Cervantes that is an
anesthetansky both players needing uh to
make uh a result uh really especially
Talia who just kind of came off of five
draws and a loss to Arena crush he's
white and uh in Anna's games Queen's
Gambit declined has been Anna's main
go-to defense throughout her career and
I always like these uh Soviet
championships where they had these
beautiful
long-winded Maneuvers where the Knight
would come all the way to G7 followed by
Bishop to F5 and you would trade off uh
the light squared Bishops uh still I
mean Sammy rashevsky and others would
say okay you get to do what you want to
do which is to trade off your light
Square in the meantime I'll end up
trying to create a weakness on the C6
Pawn with the move uh before B5
sometimes white also throws in the move
Bishop takes F6 just to create a further
imbalance but uh you know it took me
back uh a few decades there uh seeing
that
way of play by the way in the game
between Rue Yang Yan and Arena Crush we
were saying 132
132 well guess what Roo Yang went into a
deep thing after the move Bishop to D7
maybe not so familiar
Bishop F3 and by the way gift me the
pawn now I'm ready to make a capture no
you're not says Arena I'll just play
Rook A6 and as Christian was saying it's
really about preventing uh White from
playing this move B2 B4 she covers upon
on D6 and says okay do your worst by the
way slowly but surely I'm winding up for
some King side expansions with G5 and F4
or even G5 yes
that she wants to attack so we'll keep
an eye on that one and then uh Jennifer
this was the Megan Lee Queen D2 castles
Knight E5 on the board uh
I'm gonna be a very I love these games
uh Anastasia I don't know if you share
my enthusiasm Kings on opposite flanks
of course yeah
then you just go a little bit crazy uh
you you you take Liberties I want to say
uh with the play I'm not sure how do you
create an attack for in white skiing
because I don't see it right now but
maybe what she tries to say that of
course if white takes 25 you will take
with F Pawn and then you will improve
that's why we have a six pound right
absolutely no that is very nice of
course you have two Bishops so of course
it's not the case and let's say
um now maybe she will think about even
playing F5 even though she has um maybe
sometimes you can think about something
like this to activate your pieces
because this Knight on the seven maybe
is not not the best right I I see maybe
the queen kind of crawling a little bit
towards the C4 Square so maybe something
like Queen E8 Queen F7 with the idea of
um attacking the square on C4 also if
I'm going to play F5 I've got a Dodge
what might happen on the D file uh we'll
definitely keep an eye on on these two
games of our tournament co-leaders and
back over to you Christian and any more
5 10 move victories I don't think so I
would be shocked if this happens again
for the next 10 years
championships now uh let's take a look
at what's happening in the Jeffrey
versus the Wonder again because this one
is quite interesting Jeffrey we know him
occasionally he uh plays the groomfield
now let's take a look at what he did
with the white pieces C5 by a wonder and
Bishop to G2 now this is an invitation
to take on D4 and actually go for a
groomfeld take on D4 Castle White is
actually waiting for uh black to play
the move Knight to C6 the idea behind it
is if you do take on the E4 first then I
go E5 and there's no Knight to capture
on C6 so now you have to go Knight to B3
but this is a very good version for uh
black in fact black is already better
it's very similar to the grunfeld with
E3 in which white weights and just to
give you an idea of how that plays out
something along those lines of this
Knight to F3 Bishop to G7 and now E3 now
if you go D5 actually the best way to go
is take take an E4 so this is the exact
same uh situation but with reverse
colors now if we look at what happened
in the game
so white does not take on D4 immediately
waits for a Black's commitment are you
going to go G6 are you going to go E6 or
are you going to go Knight to C6 after
the move Castle Knight to C6 was the
choice by a Wonder take on D4 E5 and now
we go into one of the main lines of the
groom fell but with reversed colors
Queen to D7 this is what we have Knight
to C3 a Wonder with one hour and 30
minutes on his clock Jeffrey Sean with
one hour and three minutes now I've
analyzed this position because I was
looking I'm also a group health player
myself and I was looking at playing this
type of situations with the white pieces
also but unfortunately it doesn't seem
like it gives white a big advantage
if black knows and this is very very uh
key and what am I seeing there Knight to
C3 Rook C8 we see Rook to C8 yes that is
the best move that is the key move and
now we might see the transition into uh
the end game after taking on D5 taking
on D5 Queen takes D7 of course you
cannot recapture with one of the pieces
because you're losing the D5 Pawn you
have to take back with uh the king Rook
to D1 most likely is going to come on
the board and now there's a critical
move that black needs to know and
probably does that is Bishop to C5 the
idea is that I'm inviting you to take my
Pawn on D5 in fact I want you to take my
Pawn on D5 because if you take take we
exchange everything and then I have a
lot of compensation for the pawn you
probably have to go to D2 or D1 then I
go Rook to d8 it's very difficult to
find a spot for your Bishop if you go
Bishop to G5 sure but I'm going to go
Bishop to uh I'm going to go FC 6 if you
go back to D2 then I can go Bishop to D4
follow it up with the invasion of The
Rook on C2 my pieces are getting
extremely active and actually I have
more than enough compensation maybe even
more than equality in the position so
you have to be very careful with white
how are you going to keep the pieces on
the board one of the main lines is to
take immediate advantage of displacement
of the bishopone C5 with the move Knight
to A4 how are you going to continue as
black you don't want to give up the dark
Square Bishop because if you do that
with the two Bishops I'm going to go
Bishop to E3 Bishop to uh D2 I'm always
going to harass you on the dark Square
so you don't want to see that on the
board Bishop to D6 is one of the lines
Bishop to E7 is another one of the lines
and generally white is going to continue
it's all about this pressure on the
Square D5 on the pawn on D5 with the
move Bishop to G5 the computer is saying
that with very precise play Black will
be able to finally equalize this
position and it does seem like a Wonder
is in pole position to maybe cut this
game short because he knows exactly what
he's doing one hour and 30 minutes
Jeffrey with one hour in one minute and
if he doesn't know some precise moves to
put pressure on his opponent black is
going to equalize uh comfortably this is
what I'm expecting from a Wonder in this
game
thank you Christian
for our audience I just like to talk
about one of the big differences between
the French defense as well as the Karo
Khan so we'll start with the game
between begum and tatav and it's a
French defense and we know that tatv has
had it in a repertoire throughout her
whole career well you usually get Pawn
structures like this these are typical
Pond structures the advanced Pawn on the
E5 Square restraining black in the
center and kind of keeping this Knight
away from its most natural squares
and that is it that's what the french
defense is all about solve the problem
of the light squared Bishop is black and
you're gold you're you have a very solid
structure pretty safe King and you're
ready to
fight for control over the open C file
compare for example to the game of
Sophie and Naji here we have a Karo Khan
yes but instead of the bishop being on
the D7 Square we see the bishop outside
of the pawn chain on F5 and then if we
compare it with a game of ashrita and
Sabina
The White Square Bishop is actually gone
and again you have the French defense
Pawn structure here the trade of the
light squared Bishop white has gotten a
little bit extra space earlier in the
tournament ashrita had played this
Advanced variation and subpoena had come
prepared I like this line of play by
Sabina immediately you go Queen check
and queen D3 and you say to White well
I'm not just going to let you keep your
space you have to take along this move
c2c4 may be a move that you didn't
really want to to take along and the
players have quickly got a position
where again black is happy she's got her
Knight on F5 she's got uh
well I'm not going to say her for sure
of the center yet
of course yes sir like which position
would you prefer to play from all those
three first of all and why we need to
suffer with this bishop exactly uh you
know it's strange I actually tended
toward more towards the karakan at the
end of the my career as opposed to the
French defense but the thing I liked
about the French defense is that when I
was playing the black side it was like
the players who were white felt somehow
compelled to kill me yes like you're
obliged like you you got to destroy it
yeah and somehow the French defense
provoked a lot of players and I got in
my shots I would uh win a number of
games on the black side of the French
defense whereas when I'm playing the
Karo Khan seems like everybody's ready
to play Knight C3 and play a positional
game and not necessarily going all in so
somehow the French defense brings out
the best and worst full people of all
people all right so we'll keep an eye on
this side uh I never thought about fresh
defense from this point of view like
they really want to kill like you you
kind of provoked them to punish you for
playing so badly supposedly in the
opening keeping your Bishop far away
from the action and so on interesting
precisely and for further insights on
questions like this just want to say to
our audience you can certainly ask uh
ourselves Anastasia Christian myself any
questions that you might have you can
join the conversation and how do our
viewers do that Anastasia yeah very very
easy you follow our social media
accounts and especially you follow
Twitter accounts St Louis chess club
subscribers will get priority of course
of course yeah so 37 000 or something
like that very nice very nice and you
have to use hashtag use chess Champs or
simply if you mention simplest chess
club will still find your questions okay
please ask anything you wish
and funny you should say we've got a
couple well let's let's get the party
started and we have from John Tashi a
question so I would like Yasser to share
from his own experience as a competitor
in U.S chess chips well for me the USGS
Championship
when I was playing uh I was yes top
player uh unfortunately the national
championship was not the national
championship that it has come become
today
the U.S championships were like 14
player and 16 player events with like
half the field receiving a prize and the
other half no prize just some point
money like maybe a hundred dollars for
every point that you score so it really
wasn't a event that people wanted to
play in uh other than maybe as a
qualifier for some interzonal or or
something of that nature so I
unfortunately I declined a number of of
U.S championships however when I was
young and it was really you know eager
to play you know like to earn my spurs
it was a wonderful event because it
simply put the best players in the
United States played later in my career
I was really going to European
competitions with round Robins with
prizes for everybody so also it was a
little bit of an asymmetric risk in the
sense I was very high rated and a lot of
I I had to score like plus four plus
five plus six just to maintain my rating
today this National Championship is so
strong that even players like like
um Fabiano caruana are very very happy
to put his rating at risk exactly
yeah but uh another question please
um from well this time okay
it's great to me
when will be when will we be seeing the
Yasser Anastasia uh Christian Chris Bird
play around Robin just tournament it
will involve a ducky
for sure for sure uh no no no no uh
anxious on mice on my side to join the
competitors I'm much much more enjoy
calling the action uh off the board how
about yourself you you like the three
you like to get into a competitions now
then these days Anastasia no no not
really I don't play that much maybe
sometimes on chesscom yeah even this
famous platform right and actually it's
I prefer to play Bach house chess this
is the only days when the pledge is here
in the us when we seriously of course
when we stay named soon we keep playing
this and some strange variations of
chests right
so probably this is possible yes so
Greece and Chris yes well we're gonna
have to ask Chris Byrd the Arbiter there
he is in the beautiful Town how did he
make it to that round robin yeah I'm not
exactly sure
we want Fair
[Laughter]
player wrong rabbit I don't know the
Christian uh you you've been off the
circuit exactly for a couple of years
but you're anxious to jump back into The
Fray right yeah 2018 uh when is when I
kind of slowed it down when I started
working with uh Fabiano actually and
that took away maybe like six eight
months out of my competitive career
let's say and once you're out it's so
difficult to get back in and yes since
uh 2019 I think it was September that I
played my last classical uh game of
chess I played uh some rapid and Blitz
National a championship in 2020 but
since yeah 2019 September I haven't
played I will be playing in November
this classical uh Invitational events
here
so I'm looking forward to that I hope
I'm not gonna get killed yes
they only went to yes I'm also thinking
to play as a Greek Team Championship in
Crete and I'm playing for a small
village annoya you know this is just the
fact that in this Village Everybody
Plays chess you know they have like 1
000 people only living there and they
are big they're big fans of Chess and
they have a chess club and all kids know
how to play so I decided that this is a
this is a club I want to play for if I
ever play in Greek Greek Team
Championship yes but that's nice this
idea of a very small Greek Village where
all the play all the players all the
inhabitants pardon me yes are players
they have open events there you know you
won't be surprised yesterday maybe the
one of the most active villages in the
world so I decided you know that they
have really nice people and great food
so I couldn't resist it
nice nice
and just checking in on our fashion Mr
fashion statement of honoronian with the
I don't know what what kind of shirt you
got they're Lavon uh
yes no it's not the flowers he's got a
different arrangement I think we've seen
that yeah we've seen this before but
actually what is great about Levon I
mean he doesn't have that great
tournament so far right but we could see
him before the game so he was still like
chilling with with players with people I
mean it's really great that he tries
also to come back to I mean every time
you see him he is always in a good mood
no matter what results he's throwing
most of the times of course he is the
show with good results yeah most of the
time absolutely used to see him still
that he didn't lose his optimism
hopefully he will manage to get back to
normal let's say school yes yeah I like
to turn our attention to the game
between Fabi and uh Linderman for just a
moment because it is a very confusing
position on on the one hand black is
super happy he's got an extra Pawn in
the pocket uh
from the looks of things there are
really no discernible weaknesses in his
position in other words his Pawn
structure sound uh it again it would
appear that his development is rather
normal and then you start looking a
little bit deeper and then you kind of
saying to yourself well I'll be darn
where is
um my active play we've just seen the
move Queen B6 and I'll take it back for
just a moment because white played this
also cut off a confounding move Knight
on F3 to E1 and well what's up with that
well the first thing is that what white
really really wants in the position
let's play Queen G4 if white could play
Queen G4 Not only would he be menacing
the pawn on G7 but he would actually be
forcing Black's hand would you Castle no
you would not you would be walking into
Bishop takes H6 if you play King f8 you
lose your castling privileges so the
move Knight E1 is getting out of the way
for the move Queen G4 but more
importantly it's asking black assalian
question what exactly are you doing what
are you doing for play I'm going to play
Queen G4
play G6 I'll sacrifice a beast okay sure
uh maybe as you say F4 one day get in
that four or five let's go in the
meanwhile your extra Pawn is going to be
useful in the ending
a long time from now you know uh your
Bishop on B7 is kind of fighting on
granite frankly so the move Queen B6 is
an attempt by uh Alex to say okay uh
here's my counter play I want to take
this pawn and maybe in view of the fact
that you're preparing F4 F5 you're
preparing Queen G4 I might want to exit
stage or left and at Castle long and
that would be a very interesting uh
line to play by the way for those of you
who are looking and seeing a 1-0 by
Lanier of elshon it wasn't a forfeit it
wasn't a forfeit it was a trap that
Alshon fell for and poor elshon is
actually in a kind of a spin cycle this
happens in U.S championships where
somebody starts to have a bad result yes
everybody's like look like sharks yeah
coming after you in this crowd of sharks
they take advantage Queen B6 are we
still in um I want to say uh very in
that game between there's definitely no
more Theory no more where did it stop it
does seem like Fabi still knows what
he's doing because he's been playing
quite quickly and he's been playing the
best moves by the engine as well let's
take a look where did that stop I think
somewhere around here Rook to D1
actually in this particular
configuration was a new move but we were
sort of anticipating it because it's a
very natural move as well and actually
firuja showed him how to set up the
pieces yes
these guys are taking notes I'm telling
you during the games when they're
playing this top uh level competition
they're taking notes ah you played this
maybe I will play this later in two
years from now against uh an unknowing
opponent H6 Queen to E2 of course this
is setting up this battery with the
queen in front you would you might be
wondering why Queen to E2 right now well
you just played the move H6 so now what
black is trying to do is to go along a
short castle for example if you go
Bishop B2 I go short Castle E5 Knight to
D5 and now there's no more Pawn on H7 to
munch on right so what you want to uh do
is play this move Queen to E2 now if you
go short Castle I go E5 Knight D5 and
now the queen comes in front and I'm
threatening to give you a Checkmate so
you're kind of in trouble right now you
have to go G6 and then I pick up the
pawn on H6 actually this is close to
resignable right this position so you
cannot do that you can cannot hurry with
Castle you play the move Knight D7 E5
Knight to D5 and now this transition to
what we have currently on the board
Queen goes to B6 put some pressure on a
D4 and it doesn't commit yet to where
you're going to put the king I'm
actually wondering whether black at some
point will consider castling along it
looks a bit naked on that side right but
you don't have enough points to break my
structure you're missing one Pawn on
that side you cannot hook this Pawn on
B5 with the move A4 to force a reaction
from me so I can just simply sit like
this as it is of course it's still very
dangerous because I don't have pawns but
I have pieces right so I can go Bishop
D2 Bishop to A5 and ideas of that nature
to harass your pieces if you do decide
to go long Castle but imagine this King
Landing or flying all the way to B8 and
then the other Rook to see uh the The
Rook from d8 to C8 that's going to be
quite a healthy uh situation for a black
nevertheless right now after Bishop to
E3 still uh black has this option
shortcaster or long Castle we're going
to have to wait and see how Lenderman is
going to approach this position well but
seriously uh though Christian I see that
position and I'm standing if I'm in uh
in lenderman's shoes there's no way I'm
playing short castles I mean I'm just
walking into the hurricane
yeah that's a skit that would scare me
like no I'm not having anything to do
with that look you just munched on a
pond I'm happy but you have to suffer
for that yes Fabiano will make you
suffer a little bit whether it's going
to be decisive or not we're going to
have to wait and see it's definitely not
decisive right now but there is surely
compensation in the position for a while
absolutely I like to turn our attention
to the game between Ray Robson and our
defending Champion Wesley so what a lot
of people don't know is that Rey and
Wesley were roommates in Webster
University
can imagine all they did is play Blitz
against one another and go to class did
it go too close yeah
go to the classes as much but somewhere
between all of that dorm experience like
both players gain and I'm not joking
about 200 rating points bashing each
other and what we have here is something
very unusual uh not common at certainly
at this level when nimsovich
started this whole Trend with Bishop B4
uh an opening that bears his name one of
the things that nimsovich did is he
voluntarily gave up his Bishop Bishop
takes C3 check B take C3 and today it's
considered like you wait you don't just
give up that Bishop the knight's going
nowhere you wait for an A2 A3 you wait
for white to
invest some time and this is a very uh
unusual approach by Wesley this early
captures and E5 and after E4 rookie
eight castles well Wesley said give me
the ball yeah now if you said to me that
this position occurred out of a
I want to say a Russian defense or maybe
some kind of a Berlin I kind of get it
but coming out of a nimson which is a
little bit surprised uh for me and they
quickly got to this position where much
like Fabiano having sacrificed upon
Rey has done the same thing and Rey is
saying in this case I'm invested what
have I invested upon in for rapid and I
mean very very quick development he's
got rookie one two Bishops D5 is on his
agenda opening up this bishop keeping
this bishop alive and again if I could
get in rookie one
D5 Knight G5 it's fun and games
yeah exactly this looks really nice and
I wonder why what the Wesley can prepare
has prepared you know to right so if we
just put some moves on the board for
example Bishop seven okay rookie one I
don't know maybe I might just hold back
for a moment yes but just bear with me
and if I play D D5 what Wesley is
banking on is that that when he trades
with the move rookie eight white will
simply run out of Firepower there won't
be enough uh wood in the position for uh
Ray to land a deadly blow but again this
is a very important game for both
players as they seek to look to the
podium and for for Wesley you know both
players really do need a result Ray uh
uh
yes Westland if Wesley wants to replace
him even you know yes the position he
needs to of course win this game so
maybe he takes this kind of risk
um but and with together with the pawn
in order to try to get some game and
chances to to win it exactly uh let's
just quickly check in on the game
between uh darush and Hans Neiman this
is wow okay uh a Catalan and again
you've heard me speak about the richness
of the Catalan and how many different
approaches I've seen the players take
and well I'll echo my my words from from
the recent past a very very different
position uh from the Catalan again we
could see uh some of those similar
attacking ideas I don't know E5 you get
the pawn in the E5 you start looking
uh at possibilities of an attack going
on there if you're not happy with those
apples sometimes you could just offer a
pawn sacrifice and it can be a
completely different type of a way
you've got the F5 Square you've got
Knights I'm going to lose upon yes yeah
but I'm going to get my knight uh to C4
and again I've got quite the freedom of
movement I want to say so uh darush I
like the fact that he's the uh
um I got the more open position better
options don't forget yeah he's coming
off a nice win over Lavon with uh the
black pieces maybe he can put together a
little uh brace of Victories as we've
seen Arena crash get three in a row
we've seen Bobby uh this Victory
yesterday was really really nice really
important probably it gives you extra
self-confidence and strength to play and
to trust your instincts as well like for
example to to sacrifice the pawn in this
position it's also like you need some
kind of special mood right yes
absolutely absolutely and Christian I
jumped in what caught your attention and
just to kind of build up on that history
between Wesley so and Ray Robson because
you gave a very nice story about this
dinner starting at Webster but also
their careers overlap so much I remember
in 2014 uh the first year of millionaire
chess actually Wesley one yes in the
finals against Ray Robson and he got one
hundred thousand dollars and he actually
attributes that moment to the start of
his professional career he said once I
won that 100 000 I have a cushion to
just fall back on in case it doesn't
work out and it gave me a lot of
confidence and allowed me to pursue this
professional career as a chess player so
this was a pivotal moment in both of
this player's career so quite an
intriguing matchup that is and I was
looking at this game as well the game
that still goes on between Jeffrey Shawn
and wonder Liang and we were discussing
this position a Wonder of course he knew
this move Bishop to C5 I said this is
the critical move you don't need to
defend the spawn on D5 you cannot play
the move d4 because that will allow me
to go E3 and he will lose that pawn on
in the center so Bishop to C5 was played
by the way guys huge discrepancy on the
clock right now 40 minutes for Jeffrey
one hour 131 for Wonder Liang and
Jeffrey you know he's thinking at this
point one hour 31. he knows exactly what
he did like he's still within his
coverages I think he's in the car do his
homework
he wants to build this game as soon as
possible he definitely did his homework
in on this one and right now Jeffrey has
a big Choice do you take on the uh D5
and make a drop because you know that
after you take on D5 most likely that
one is just simply going to end or you
try to continue the game with the move
Knight to A4 but once again you see the
preparation that your opponent came up
with you know he knows more than you do
in the position and you're also falling
behind on the clock significantly what
is the choice that you guys would make
in this situation would you continue
with Knight A4 or would you take on D5
and that assumes that you know the move
Knight waveform yeah again I you gotta
play the hand that's been dealt the
Practical
um trumps everything else you're you're
behind on the clock your opponent knows
the position better than you do you take
the repetition you take on D5 you force
a draw we've seen Alex Linderman very
reluctantly I must say accepting draws
but uh facing the harsh reality that uh
the other choices are maybe too risky
and I think we might actually see a
result guys just uh to interrupt you for
a second Levon and Chris for you are
repeating in fact wow that happened
quickly now yes yes probably once said
enough is enough it's
over over as uh you're absolutely right
the players repeated and I don't know if
this is one of those fashionable
Grandmaster draws or not
is it
um
difficult to say this patient hasn't
been seen before so I cannot call it a
fashionable Grandmaster draw since it
hasn't been seen but it's funny because
Christopher actually tried to uh pursue
the example that a wander set with a
Gambit of his own against Levon also
with this D4 after Bishop to C4 Knight
to F6 so quite an interesting opening
choice but this time Levon was ready
this time Levon did not fall under uh
the sharp sword of his opponent's
preparation absolutely yeah maybe it's
not a bad idea just to make a draw and
have a break with black pieces today
fully one and then again one more
youngster
teenagers is Wesley put it exactly but
on the other hand you know you you kind
of feel the Eternal Tournament ebbing
away how many chances are you going to
get I mean 15 year old is 15 year old
you do want to try to exploit them at
that age and beat them while they're
young yes sir yes probably you would try
to check them exactly or you give a draw
indeed I want to will the real Sam
please stand up uh the game between Sam
shacklin and Sam Savion uh they're
they're playing an open Spanish and I
have to say it sure looks to my eyes
like both players are really
theoretically well prepared as they go
down this uh quite topical line
the open Spanish again one of those
openings that waxes and wanes players
like Victor korchnoy and the swanathan
championed it on the white side
and recently we've been seeing I think
it was uh the candidates uh tournament
in Madrid and I believe it was
um
chacriar also likes to play on the black
side of the opening open uh the move
uh Sam Shanklin uh played Bishop F4
that's a novelty according to my I'm
seeing A4 I'm seeing Bishop takes G5 I'm
saying Queen E1 quite a number of moves
have been played exactly in this
position again Bishop takes G5 another
move pretty much everything that looks
reasonable H4 looks a little bit
excessive but Bishop F4 a novelty
um by the way this phone was not hanging
right Queen E5 F4 right so yeah it's not
immediately hanging the question is how
am I what am I supposed to do I mean uh
if I don't do it something in quickly
maybe this queen moves and the Knight
will take up a nice residency on the E6
Square it would be a really really uh
Knights are great blockaders so the move
Bishop F4 I think is a kind of a Prelude
to putting pressure against the Knight
Bishop F4 Rook d8 King H1 I'm wrong King
h8 who could guess these moves Queen
d2h6h4 Knight H7 and to help me with the
clock times because if I'm reading this
right Sam is not spending time thank you
hasn't spent a single uh two minutes
yeah just banging them out see two and
all of this is in Sam shanklin's
preparation and more than 30 minutes 40
minutes has been used by some Savion
we'll keep an eye on that but Christian
over to you as we have a guest in studio
Lavon a difficult tournament for you up
to this point definitely according to
your standards uh sum it up for us up to
this point
yeah I think
you know
maybe I've been uh pushing too much I
think this game against
against the Wonder
I mean
I've played this line zillion times with
white and bullets and queen D6 list to
draw I mean instead of rookie eight and
the other thing and I thought okay I
have to keep the game going and I
planted this bishop D2 so that was uh a
bit
a bit of a surprise and against Darius
yeah I should have settled for a draw in
that position and I knew that he has too
much Hunter play and I should just play
I saw the draw and then once again I
think I've been uh
maybe underestimating my opponents and
they've been playing very well so this
is the result and today I decided okay
no more underestimate I gotta get a
place according to the position and this
is something that Wesley was mentioning
as well he always has problems with the
teenagers he was saying that he loses a
lot with the teenagers uh they're
definitely very very strong are you
surprised by their strength or not so
much no you know if if we just think
about it
this kid's especially this Asian kids
you know they're I mean to get here from
Asia your father or mother has to be a
fantastic specialist so it means they
have great gyms absolutely and it means
they're very very talented so I'm not
too surprised that they're playing very
well I'm actually a fan of all of these
players not just the Asian kids but
every every
a young guy that is playing here I think
they're very very talented let's speak
about today's game because he was
starting the game into one of these
gambits maybe he was looking to follow
up I don't know wonders footsteps uh
were you surprised by his opening choice
at all were you worried about it
I I knew that there is a line like this
you know there are many options for
black but I knew that Knight E4 is maybe
expecting the fried liver oh yeah always
ready always ready yes and he played D4
yeah and yeah Knight E4 I think is a
solid option generally
no no I mean F35 sorry
what I played yes I'm here yeah I think
the main Theory goes Bishop D5 instead
of the usual D5 right yeah it should be
five yeah but uh you know why why I mean
D5 is a long long unknown Theory I mean
there is no reason to choose something
uh that is well played many times you
can also play something that is played
less absolutely and uh did it feel like
he knew what he's doing was he moving
quickly more or less knew this bishop G5
stuff I think if you don't play Bishop
G5 then it can be slightly worse for
white I think CD castle and then black
is
yeah like
gets the queen of two F6 Knight to F4 I
mean it's still around equal I think
generally but Bishop G5 is the most
solid we have some weaknesses to play
against right Bishop to G5 instead of
taking on D4 yeah and I I kind of have
to play Knight F4 I think
because castle c take d uh Knight F4
Queen E3 I think that's that you need to
know I mean I think there is also
instead of neither four there is Knight
at that moment there is Knight G5
but yeah Knight C3 or yeah this can be
slightly worse for black this end game
you have some problems on the C5 so
Knight F4 I think you need to know that
you shouldn't Castle first you should
play Knight F4 and the rest uh kind of
finds by itself the rest is history we
have to ask you about this moment that
shocked us or this game between linear
and elshon did you see what happened
yeah particular moment uh yeah I think
uh El Sean forgot to take on C4 I think
if you play this line with Bishop F5 yes
after C4 you you have to take
because if you don't take well there is
this what happened in the game do you
attribute this to him probably playing
for one of the first times the Petrov
elshon that is oh could be could be well
but I think uh he's a very good player
but he got affected by yesterday I think
you know the position that you see after
E5
well after Knight D5 it looks like such
a pleasant position and instead he
played Bishop G4 which I actually also
blundered that there is the stage five
idea I thought oh Bishop G4 is
interesting but yeah generally I think
he got affected by yesterday's loss from
good position and maybe his nerves were
not perfect today yes an unfortunate
series of events in this one but this is
indeed competition here at the U.S
championships Levon congratulations uh
we'll see you in the rest of your games
thank you
congratulations
[Laughter]
but can I actually congratulate the one
of course a bit later but he had a
birthday a few days ago and we didn't
have chance to tell you but we said
congratulations yes so that's why yes we
have congratulations too but I was just
wondering you have accomplished so much
let's say and have you thought about
let's say your life you know when you
reach this number always those kind of
thoughts they go through your mind I
mean what what can you say about let's
say your this date and how did you
celebrate it
oh yeah well I think this is uh
more or less General tradition in uh
maybe Orthodox Christianity we don't
celebrate the 40th birthday yes so I
didn't really celebrate it uh yes you
know I just had dinner
but uh Annie and her mom
um but uh
regarding to the age
you know why
I don't look at it that way like oh you
get a certain why why it should be 40 or
not 41 or or not 39. so I I think
I I know that I accomplished a lot and
then I and I always look to learn more
you know life is there to experience and
to learn things speaking of experiencing
a life Lavon you also have a baby coming
uh next month how are the preparations
going for that moment
I'm very excited
are you tired are you having any
sleepless nights thinking about that
moment at all or not so much just
excitement just excitement more or less
yeah yeah that's great uh and Lavon just
to let you know I I'm I'm your
babysitter guy I I love kids I'm ready
to go you need a break just uh just
knock on the door if you
babysites I babysit Jennifer ten times
worse than you commenting I will take
you I will take you because I love you
your baby's gonna love me you wait you
wait and see just don't tell some of
this naughty stories you know
not a problem not a problem just uh
knock on the door that's all we ask good
luck uh in the second half uh Lavon
thank you as we prepare for a break uh
just tell us uh what's happening uh our
mates rates at uh Q Boutique what do we
got for them today yes we have a very
nice T-shirt with the logo yesterday one
of the actually it's one of the most
popular items in cubic shop the Saint
Louis chess club branded t-shirt and
it's available right now when you shop
online at cubic St louis.com so you can
also find it in the Hall of Fame shop I
mean this is what I'm going to do myself
and I really like this logo yeah it
looks beautiful that silver logo on a
black background looks really nice and
as we do go on on our break uh we asked
the players uh what in the open section
pardon me we asked them what their
expectations were coming into these U.S
championships have a look and we'll see
you on the other side of the break
[Music]
this is a very strong tournament
including a mix of young Thailand as
well as experience what are your
expectations about this tournament
seeing that chess in the United States
is thriving and there's so many young
intelligent players that is very
exciting in general and one very
exciting thing for me personally is
getting to play against a lot of guys
that I haven't played in my life yet so
this is interesting honestly I think if
I apply my best chest and I don't get
lucky I'm probably not going to win and
if I play my absolute best stress and I
do get lucky then I probably will win uh
so part of that is within my control 2
degree and part of it is not so just
focus on like control put the best
stress you can and hope for the best uh
well when it first started playing I was
in FM so I didn't have much expectations
my goal was to play as well as they
could and then try to improve that on
the next year
but as I've gotten stronger um you know
the tournament's gotten stronger as well
you know my only goal is to make sure
that I'm I can just play the way I'm
capable of playing at my best and uh you
know of course give it my maximum effort
for every game and uh and see what
happens I think as long as I can play my
my best chess and show what I'm capable
of winning the tournaments not out of
the realm possibility
um for me it was just a unique challenge
that you know once it got the invite I
was like I have to play the the US
Championship you know even even missing
like three weeks of school it's gonna be
it's gonna be tough but you know I I
just made other arrangements and yeah I
think it's something that I would do you
know no matter what I didn't I don't
really have that many expectations but I
want to play fun chess I don't want to
get boring games hopefully
my opponents don't listen to this
interview because maybe now they're
gonna try to make it like super boring
so nice that uh you get a chance to face
guys like Fabiano Lavon Wesley Lanier
all these great players
um I think that's made a tremendous
impact in
getting that experience to play these
world-class guys uh as for what I expect
I I'm just trying to play good chess
here I think
whatever Resort comes I'm I'll be fine
with it I just want to play well I mean
I'm still having nightmares over my loss
to fear with Jeff from a month ago but
uh yeah certainly it's fun and exciting
also this year we have more players more
rounds so it's going to be a long-end
challenging tournament so it's going to
be interesting now that the tournament's
getting stronger and to try to win more
titles is going to be more challenging
but but it's fun because you get to play
against top players also up and coming
players such as Crystal Fairview and I
wonder
yeah it's it's a challenge you know it's
uh obviously getting super strong not
only we we got one more
um super DM like Levon uh but also the
the the younger players
um they they seem to to be getting
stronger which is normal and uh and then
the combination of the the super DMS
with the with the the younger players
were obviously improving and getting uh
stronger and stronger makes it for I
think a really great field of players
and but I like that I mean I liked uh to
to play Such tournaments and
look forward to to the challenge well I
would say that for the past
since 2014 and 2015.
like the two main goals that I had in
chess that were unfulfilled where I went
to cross 2700 and win at least one U.S
Championship so I still haven't done
either of those although I'm close to
2700 now and I've been close in a couple
of championships had some chances so
yeah obviously I do really want to win
this tournament one day hopefully it's
this year I mean that that's my goal but
um yeah I know it's it's going to be
very difficult I I hope that I can fight
for the first place last year I I fought
for first place I didn't make it uh and
and misery at Levon is a new addition to
the tournament and to us chess scene and
uh and all the usual usual guys you know
Wesley is the defending champ so I guess
he's the man to beat this year but we
also have a lot of newcomers or guys
that you don't normally see in the US
Championship so that would also be
interesting
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
and welcome back to round seven of the
U.S championships and we have results in
an open section Christopher you made the
draw against lebonaron and we also have
a one decisive result linear Domingo's
outplayed elshon
um I mean in 20 minutes it was just a 20
minutes game it was a trap that Alshon
fell for and it showed his unfamiliarity
in this Russian defense and loss
yes in a snap and it was really that
quick it wasn't a forfeit as we get
ready for a very special guest coming up
I just want to point out the game
between Ray Robson and Wesley so as
essentially Rey sacrificed upon early
for the two Bishops very promising
looking attack but how are we really
going to do anything well Ray had an
idea he's going to play the move G4
again to try to get some weaknesses if
you play the move G7 G6 well this bishop
is going to be smiling for the rest of
the game
a very happy Bishop indeed
c7c6 and this strikes me as it might be
badly mistimed as white we can see that
white wants to combine The Rook coming
to G1 with the pawn coming to G5 and Rey
is coming fast and fury is in this one I
think Wesley is in some trouble as we'll
keep an eye on this I was expecting
maybe the move B5 to undermine the pawn
on D5 this away but Christian is with a
very special guest oh not yet
you were warming up uh Jump Right In on
the Wesley gate I'm not with again yes
more chess the guest is trust right now
so after C6 we were discussing about
this position and it's actually very
concrete it's it's not easy to see so
check this line out take G5 now if you
take uh the second Pawn on D5 this is
the big problem you give a check first
okay you get the king to a trade so that
it cannot run away and now you play this
move critical move in my opinion Bishop
to F5 with an immediate threat the
threat is to just simply take on D7 you
cannot recapture back Knight takes D7
because Queen to H7 is coming so he
needs to see this uh sequence of moves
and of course by the way this is not the
best way for black to defend instead of
taking the pawn probably the best way to
do it is to go Queen to uh E7 and right
now another critical move not Bishop to
H7 check because now I can run the other
way and actually that makes my king safe
safer in the position but rather start
with the move Bishop to F5 once again
the same ideas come into play Bishop
takes D7 followed by Bishop takes F6 if
you do take with the queen and then the
invasion via Queen to H7 so you have a
lot of things to worry about and if you
try to block it with the move G6 yeah
good luck surviving this attack not only
that my queen is coming into play my
Rook is ready to jump to G1 and come
into play as well after Queen to G7 I
just dropped back to F5 Rook to G1 is
coming next I am a piece down but it
doesn't matter this position is
completely over and black will get mated
on the king side so a big moment right
now and by the way after King to H2 C6
instead of C6
if white if black excuse me Wesley so
plays the move Rook to E8 and try to get
his pieces back into uh the defense
faster the position remains complex also
after C6 in fact the engine is thinking
for the first couple of minutes and
actually doesn't see the fact that white
is winning so the variations are not
easy to spot even uh by the engine at
the beginning it says zero zero zero
later on if you let it think for a
little bit it jumps to plus 1.06 so
quite decisive Advantage nevertheless
white needs to remain precise in the
position and this is not going to be
easy but a golden opportunity for the
streaking right now Ray Robson who's
been yeah well he won yesterday against
Hans Neiman with the black piece is a
brilliant game he has a golden
opportunity right now to take down the
defending Champion Wesley so but
actually he proved that he can be
precise yes oh yes yes yesterday here
with the game with uh Hansen he really
threaded the needle very well I want to
turn our attention to Fabi our
tournament leader in the open for just a
second in this game with Alex Thunderman
because I found this move Knight E1 a
really nice move I I I love this
maneuver a lot and after Queen B6 not
the move Bishop E3 but immediately Queen
G4 asking Alex a question are you going
to Castle or go King f8 no G7 G6 that
weakness that and when we when we talk
about weakness we're talking
specifically about the pawns once you
play G6 it's almost an absolute you're
not going to go to Castle short so with
the move Bishop D2 Fabi said okay now
please do Castle along oh yeah so that I
can go Bishop A5 no now you have to play
B4 so when the pawns were on B5 wave and
Asics it's a little bit hard to attack
the structure with the pawns on B4 it
means that castling I have a much more
straightforward way of attacking the
pawn on Asics so that little Nuance gave
Fabi the timing he needed to play Bishop
E3 A5 Queen E2 and again he's kind of
thinking in his mind you're not castling
kingside
you're not going to Castle Queen side
because I'm ready to embrace you over
there now I'll start to find a square
for my knight oftentimes we see White
Plain G3 H4 Knight comes to
um F4 I'm very very curious I find this
game these Maneuvers inspiring so we'll
keep this game and Christian now we have
a guess took you a while tell us about
our guests we do indeed we are here with
uh Brian Owens Brian first of all
welcome to the show you uh curate the
performances at the world chest Hall of
Fame tell us a bit your work there yeah
so I'm one of the music series directors
and also I'm artist residence so that's
the cool part because I get to do things
like the Fisher piece that we did in
honor of the opening ceremony and the
the anniversary of the the Fishers
basket a match so um you know just being
able to really you know Define and kind
of find those those play places where
chess and music line up and meet they're
both Universal languages to me and so I
just I love being able to delve more
into to how they marry one another tell
us a bit about that experience at the
singfield cup how did you come up with
the idea for the song
um well
I worked with a couple people one a guy
named Adam Manis who is one of the
greatest Rangers in this city Keon
Harold and hip-hop artist Mastermind and
what we did was we got together and I
watched the Bobby Fischer documentary
and I took the different aspects of his
life and we turned those into movements
and it was really cool because
so much of the music that he loved was
well represented in the year of 1972. so
we we just kind of filled in the gaps of
the original music that we composed
around like if there were a film about
this moment what would it sound like and
uh I think what it came out to be was
pretty special yeah did you get to train
any chest in preparation
for that Performance Food is full
disclosure this is this is my chest life
I barely beat my five-year-old daughter
which would probably make my net rating
about 2.5 okay so um
you know um so no I mean I've I've
always had an affinity for the game of
chess even though I didn't play chess
until later into my life but that's how
I kind of view chess it's kind of like
music in a similar way like even people
who've never picked up an instrument or
who've never been professionally
involved with the art or the craft they
understand what it is and I think that's
why you know our involvement from the
creative space moving into how it
interacts with the chess world is so
it's so sweet I mean there's so many
correlations they're both improvisatory
they both take strategy so I think with
with those kind of elements being being
kind of parallel and crossover it makes
it makes it really cool absolutely in
fact let's take a look at one of your
performances right now
[Music]
the sorrow yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a broken heart
[Music]
how can you stop the rain from falling
down
that also Sunshine is
[Music]
a broken leg
[Music]
talk to me a bit about those moments in
front of the crowd at the worship Hall
of Fame how do you feel at that point uh
it's a really cool setting to be in I
feel like it's just big enough just
small enough it feels like an intimate
atmosphere
but you can have obviously we had you
know a full stream quartet and piano and
a band
um having people be close to the to the
the intimacy of the experience and the
music I think is a really cool cool
thing not just for me but for all the
artists who who get to perform
throughout the year uh in the series and
that's what we're really trying to go
for is really having music that fits the
the intimacy and the acoustic nature of
that space
um so I don't know man it's it's it's
been a lot of fun this is my first year
I performed on the series in years prior
but this is my first year as kind of
being the music director and curator and
um it's just been a lot of fun it's been
a lot just again finding those
correlations between chess and the
creative space
um and there's no shortage of them so I
think like being in that space is it's
just it's an amazing experience yeah and
how can the public interact with you
guys uh do they have tickets uh yeah I
mean if you want what's the schedule
yeah we have we have monthly shows you
can find at the schedule by going to the
World Chess Hall of Fame website and
checking out the music series we have a
chamber music series that Brian Woods
overseas and I ever I see I guess the
non-chamber music series
um and then you know as we go along
throughout like the rest of this year
and next year we're going to get into
other experiences that we'll be
providing for the community and of
course you can check it out online
through the YouTube channel and through
the website with the World Chess Hall of
Fame Brian thank you very much for uh
joining the show thank you for uh what
you're doing with the workshest Hall of
Fame great work absolutely thank you
uh Brian first of all I just got to ask
a quick question uh and a a big big big
thank you I thought that your song on
the Bobby Fischer was really
extraordinary one of the most original
songs I've ever heard and I loved it I
simply just absolutely absolutely loved
it and I wanted to tell you that in 1992
I visited saffron Yugoslavia where I
spent uh time with Bobby Fischer and he
recited to me all of these lyrics of all
of these songs from Motown dude had it
down and I said well Bobby you you're
really stunning me did you ever try to
write a song he said yes sir I did I did
I I Bobby sat down for a whole week with
a with a paper
and he said nothing came out because
nothing happened yeah where do you get
your inspiration
that would be the equivalent of me being
like I really love chess and I sit down
for a whole week and nothing comes out
it's the same you know and we you know
we talked about this Joshua I mean the
same way you know how did you get a
chess genius
you can be born with with the potential
for greatness but if you don't tap into
it you'll never realize it the same
amount of hours that Bobby Fischer put
into becoming a chess genius or Boris
spasky or any number of of folks who
have been on that level
the people that you whose music you love
and appreciate they put that same amount
of time into it because it's like it's a
craft and I believe that
chess is an art
and a craft yeah I have also one
question I mean um you said that you
went through many documentaries before
you wrote the song and um actually I was
wondering what impressed you the most
from what you've seen about Bobby Fisher
or what you've heard about the match
anything which kind of impressed you
so this is how do I put this
Bobby Fischer had a little gangster in
him
got from from those documentaries is
that you know Bobby Fischer had had a
little gangster in him and it's it's a
very American like like the way in which
he approached the game and approached
his brand uh was was was
quintessentially a American
um
but I but I also I also had compassion
to foresee him in those moments of
loneliness living that life being
isolated and being so locked into one
thing
um so I think you you kind of see the
blessing and the curse of it him winning
the match and his life completely
changing because he can no longer be
that isolated person
um so I don't know like I I it's like I
see the gentle gangster
Rebel with a cause Brian thank you for
all that you do and we will see you at
the World Chess Hall of Fame I love
those dinners where you share about the
many many musical artists that came from
St Louis yes I was stunned by the depth
and history of the city where music is
concerned thank you so much share some
music that's what we're doing
thank you for the edumacation
absolutely as we jump in uh back to the
game between Ray Robinson and Wesley so
guess what yeah uh Ray uh picked up the
gauntlet threw it down G5 HG Knight
takes G5 and uh they it it's really on
Wesley to now answer these threats what
are they well let's just take a look if
you uh pardon me if you were to capture
this Pawn you follow up with the c7c6 uh
this move Bishop uh H7 check is a nice
little touch maybe on a good day Queen
E7 King f8 The King can Trot away from
this open G file by putting forcing the
king first back to the king side King h8
now Bishop F5 Bishop takes and queen H7
if you make a move well a terrible mood
yeah this is where where it all goes
wrong it unravels in the that Checkmate
that Christian pointed out on the other
hand if you try to move the Knight 95
you walking into F2 F4 and once again
there aren't many blockers uh yeah
you're welcome to take this Bond if you
like but oh you can just imagine how
easy it will be for white to decisively
score in a uh
immediately maybe or even even know it
uh and I understand there's breaking
news in hans's game that there are
indeed the breaking news and Khan's
position is breaking right now you're
breaking it's completely shattered how's
this position check this out check this
transition after Knight to C4 Queen to
A8 what are you doing with that Queen on
eight I understand you're putting some
pressure but when are you going to move
this Knight away from D5 you're going to
drop the Knight on D7 you cannot do this
Knight takes E5 Knight to D6 Bishop
takes D6 Knight to G5 first an
Intermezzo version two bomb in the
position check this out you play G6 I
take on D6 now my uh Bishop is open the
long diagonal is open not only that but
after the move Queen to B8 guess what I
have a couple of Rooks coming into play
as well brooklips if you go King takes
H7 after Rook to C4 there is no way you
can defend uh against the onslaught
that's coming on the king side you can
try to do something like F6 but after
Rook to H4 King 2 G7 Rook to G4 how are
you defending the pawn on G6 you want to
go Knight E7 no no no no can do that
pawn on D6 is looking nice right now do
you want to play G5 no can do check this
out the pawn on F6 is uh pinned by the
bishop on B2 every single one of white
species are playing an active role into
the attack and it shows the king is
completely exposed there's no way to fly
the queen to E8 once again we come to
the idea of flying pieces once uh per a
game you cannot do that of course Queen
to E8 is not a possibility you're
getting checkmated you have to sacrifice
the Knight with Knight to A4 but this is
actually not going to help you too much
I'm just picking it up and once again
you have the same problem you have to
give me another piece with Bishop to E4
game is over so Knight to H7 this is a
big one you probably cannot touch that
Knight you have to go Rook to d8 but if
you want to go Rook d8 I take on D5 I
follow that up with Knight to F6 and
then the queen is going to land on the
board as well or I can just simply go
Rook to C4 I'm still thinking about the
same ideas Rook to H4 now also emptying
the square C1 for my queen so Queen to
C1 Queen to H6 is becoming a reality in
the position
this one well somebody wake hands up
because this one is not looking good and
look at his body sure he knows it look
at that yes she's almost smiling like I
got this he's on the prowl right now
he's ready to pounce yes he is you know
for a good move you don't have to take
on H7 first you can go Rook to C4 okay
but I like Knight H7 it's okay 97 is
coming Knight H7 was was a blow but I
have to tell you I'm very I would have
probably played Rook C4 myself no 937
to give my check this out you you'll
love this Anastasia if you go Queen
takes D6 why else did you play Queen B8
right I go Rook H4 and I could play
Knight H7 now if you go H5 let me wake
you up okay if you can I didn't
sacrifice anything and let me introduce
uh my Rook uh Rook h8 is going to be
made I understand the move Rook C4 I
think Knight H7 was very very strong but
boy just you know Rook C4 is a great
movie you just uh just finished the game
yeah you're just coming with with
everybody is landing on the king side no
guards very nice very nice very nice but
nothing other than the Rook is actually
guarding the king so this looks like a
completely crushing attack let's jump
back because the Rave for Wesley so it's
also our defending Champion you know
he's he's been
suffering uh in the 2022 US
championships actually two top players I
mean
two favorites yes they don't really the
results yeah the results let's say
they're not so great so far exactly and
Wesley he said look I I still don't see
the attack or maybe I do but I have no
choice at this point
just played the move c6d5 and this is
again I want to say sometimes you know
you get these opportunities where you're
given really beautiful options and then
you kind of get stuck uh if I'm in
ratios I'm sitting there saying oh Rook
G1 is just magnificent I bring another
attacker the G file a secret geometry
please
like do me this great favor of taking
the pawn so now we can see that I mean
literally attacking with everybody bang
bang bang bang bang
so the move Rook G1 is very seductive
and Christian is Rook G1 a bad move or
is it just that Bishop H7 is so much
better no no Bishop H7 is the only move
it's the only move to give you the uh
decisive advantage that we were
discussing about Bishop to H7 followed
by Bishop to F5 so he needs to find
these very precise sequence of moves to
continue the attack and continue
building up the pressure with decisive
threats and this is uh what it's all
about in this position because you
sacrifice two pawns yeah
why is Rook G1 it does but I will just
simply go Queen
um
exactly this is my escape plan right
0.37 get out of Dodge King to f8 also
Queen to E7 gets ready to play the move
at Knight to E5 and get the Knight into
the uh attack as well because you have
some ideas with Knight to F3 so you have
to be careful as white also so very
tempting I'll give you that guys Rook to
G1 is really really tempting and uh
Robson right now how many minutes is he
on C takes D5 oh 44 minutes even more
this is a luxury for Ray Robinson right
at this point usually he has 30 seconds
and playing on increment this is move 20
still 20 moves to go a lot by the way
guys the assessment right now it says
three points yeah so it's raining
completely right completely winning okay
normally this idea is typical yes and
then you go back with your Bishop
provoking the skink on a chat even
without all this all the other
variations like it's kind of uh typical
and I'm trying to understand where is
the Saving Grace for black right because
okay D4 I see this is what it's proposed
but what if I just take take and even
Queen to F2 and try to get come and
Checkmate you like this right because
the Checkmate doesn't come as easily you
still have Queen to B4 ideas apparently
once again it's all about trying to run
away with the King on the other side to
f8 right
crazy position but once again a golden
opportunity for Ray Robson to
potentially take down Wesley so inflict
his second defeat in the tournament
Wesley's that is and you can see on his
face he doesn't look confident he seems
a bit concerned about his situation I
think he prefers to check others in
other games then his own game you know
let's take a look what's going on in
other words by the way I want to say
that this is also something that
professionals are now today especially
training themselves to do when I played
in a lot of tournaments I didn't have
what we call uh the the big wall boards
where the audience I didn't have an
audience no so you know the only
perspective I had was looking at it from
my point of view on on the board but
then sometimes you go up on the Monitor
and you see it from the white side you
go oh my God I'd love to be white
at the time that you were sitting at in
front of your board you were thinking oh
I'm defending nicely yes but then you
see a different perspective so a lot of
times you do and there you get an idea
of the all the games the players can see
the games they as they're getting a
coffee or a snack or whatever they look
up and they go oh I like honest oh no
that's not Anna's position that's my
position
that's not and there you go you see Sam
as well no I have a question for you
guys please uh in general when you're in
a worse position and you have these type
of gadgets around you where you can see
all the games do you shy away from your
own game you like to get up and start
looking at basically avoid what's
happening on your own board are you
trying to do that right speaking only
for myself I can say absolutely not the
way I look at it when I'm sitting down
playing a game of chess nothing else
exists
that's important is my game not Gary
kasparovsk's game not the brilliancy of
the tournament that's taking place on
the board next to me but just my own so
I my attitude is that I'm going to look
at the brilliancy afterwards but in the
meanwhile I'll look at one of the things
that really shocked me was Gary because
sparov himself was in my first Olympiad
it was also Gary's first Olympiad uh you
know I had heard a lot about Gary like
he was this up and coming guy and he's
going to be challenging Anatoly karpov
and I had it in my mind somebody who had
a complete narrow Focus only his own
games Gary gets up from the board he
looks at every card in the whole
Olympiad man like everything was in
interesting and then he would run back
to his board when it was his move and I
thought that was stunning because I had
totally the opposite attitude how about
yourself interesting approach I mean
that you are concentrated only on my
game nothing else exists unfortunately
maybe that's why I didn't play so well
I mean I would also like to check what's
going on on the other boards but you
know what I remember a couple of funny
stories about it like I remember Elena
denilan telling me that she is getting
really tired during Team Championships
and I asked her why because she said
because I play four games at the same
time I'm not only playing my game I'm
also checking what's going on on other
boards and as a leader of the team she
probably kind of makes decision even how
to play her own game and another thing
which I wanted to mention like there is
this Grandmaster Janis papayano from
Greece the first Board of Greek national
team there are some you know legends
about his memory that he can remember
even all games in the plane Hall you
know he stands up he instead of playing
his own game he checks the others and uh
I mean they say that he could recall
most of the games that he could even
show what happened and which work or
less that's a lot of truth but uh jump
in onto your own question Christian
you're the chess coach of
Mizzou and you tell your players what
well uh in regards to that question I
tell them to sit on their hands at the
board and not get up but of course every
single player it's all about personality
right right I myself uh personally like
to walk a lot and look at other games
and try to uh clear my mind and I know
that's bad I know from a technical point
of view that's actually the wrong
attitude because you're losing a lot of
time on your opponent's clock where you
could be thinking and you could uh be uh
delving deeper in to the position so I
definitely tell my students hey yes sure
I understand especially if you're
playing at the big open tournament or at
the Olympiad or anything of that nature
there's a lot of interesting games going
on around you but what you should be
focused on is your own game because the
result in your own game is what matters
to you first and foremost no but on the
other hand you know sometimes when you
focus too much and it depends yes on
every person like sometimes you really
want your brain to stop working for a
few seconds to recharge the battery so
probably this is how it works with me
like I cannot really if I think about my
bad position all the time probably I
feel really bad yeah I don't need to
change my focus I agree with that and
one player's advice uh Victor coachnoy
he really felt like sometimes you have
to disconnect from your game just kind
of recharge he would go to the bathroom
it just splash his face with the coldest
water he could I mean he it's almost
like let's wake up yes and then he would
dry his face vigorously so it's like
almost like you get a smack in the face
and then he would come back kind of like
recharge replenished but not looking at
the other games there's a real real
problem and I think all of this has
fallen for this trap is we do find a
game it is absolutely fascinating and
then we look like how did they get here
and pretty soon you're giving more
energy to this other game than to your
own you've really fall headlong into uh
this trap there we see by the way I
think that's a Wonder Liang
in this game against Jeffrey Jean I
really wanted to turn our attention if
we could just to the game between the
two Sams because I absolutely find this
uh position uh fascinating
um when you start to think about the
imbalances for just a second you you'll
understand where I'm coming from White
has the two Bishops yes great okay so
yeah Applause secondly we have a
protective pass bomb yeah on uh the E5
Square really really really Applause so
what does our poor opponent have well
he's got a majority yeah he's doubled on
the open file that's pretty good the
Knight on H7 is terrible really really
really bad but it's the promised land is
the E6 square if we could put if we
could maneuver the Knight to the E6
where we blockade this pawn and by the
way we have a little offense going the
Knight will be able to jump capture the
pawn on F4 in the meanwhile we'll take a
look at this bishop remember we we
loaded our two Bishops a moment ago but
that second Bishop that Bishop on C2 at
the moment is really not bothering black
so I'm having a difficult time uh
summing up who I think could potentially
stand better and I haven't come up with
a judgment on this one help me bail me
out here uh Kristen what's the
evaluation it's it's it's difficult
indeed and I I think you hit the nail on
the head uh this one is not easy to
assess because as you were mentioning
black has its own trumps in the position
once you get the queen out of E6 the
Knight could potentially jump to E6 once
you set up the blockade on the E6 square
with a knight well you're going to have
a very powerful majority on the Kings on
the queen side right down the board so
the assessment at least according to the
engine is still white is better but is
very very unclear Rook takes D5 seems to
be the best move Queen takes D5 follow
it up with Rook D1 actually try to
exchange which which is a bit
counter-intuitive try to exchange the
roofs right because usually we know that
Rooks work very well with Bishops and
the queen in general works better with
the Knight Queen and Knight coordination
is better than Queen and Bishop at least
according uh to the rulebook yeah
cultural Rule books fight with you about
these ideas but okay of course modern
chess is very different and positions
that we encounter in modern chess uh
differ uh very much so this one is one
in particular it feels like because with
the bishop especially with dark swear
Bishop you can create a lot of threats
against the king you have ideas such as
Bishop to D4 following it up with E6 and
if you can connect the bishop and the
Queen on the long diagonal yeah good
luck defending against uh all the
trackmates coming on that diagonal so
very intriguing position Queen 28 Queen
to C6 I would say forget about the
computer assessment forget about the
fact that it says plus 0.4 it is still a
very tense middle game position and is
very unclear who stands better I think
this is a game for three results right
now exactly and by the way do we have to
recapture with the queen on D5 no if we
recaptured with the Rook no no no and
the idea being that again I want to make
the blockade with the Knight but maybe
Queen could go back to DC so I could
threaten Rook D2 on a good day so maybe
like Rook to D1 well then I go in Knight
f8 I'm just uh what you can do is go
Knight to F6 wow we're using the fact
check this idea out right oh this is
looking pretty good right now it comes
to G4 maybe d5u if you take on D5 put a
lot of pressure on F4 there is a lot of
pressure in the position on f4 on H4 uh
the pawns are also coming down the board
for example if you go G3 I go Queen to
C6 or Knight to B4
I'm the one that's black attacking your
pieces I'm the one gaining momentum in
the position so it definitely feels like
black is faring quite well in uh this
setup we're going to have to wait and
see how these players are going to
develop this intriguing middle game
Knight F6 by the way that was a blind
spot oftentimes I think with a lot of
grand Masters whenever we see a pawn
attacking a square we automatically shy
away from putting our pieces on pre to
the pawn but the Knight H7 to F6
potentially jumping the G4 makes you all
almost ask the question why didn't we do
it last time you know like like why did
we play Rook D1 uh maybe we could have
gotten away with this one I'm not sure
uh anyway I I find this uh to be a
fascinating game Let's jump to our
ladies and uh share what's going on with
our leaders first we'll start with our
eight time
um US champion Arena Crush when we left
it it was this fashnikov a very
um awkward swishnikov where white was
trying to get and Rue Yang Yan was
trying to get in before but let me
interrupt myself
to say that darush is smashing attack as
he takes down Hans Neiman and maybe one
of our best games of the tournament
wow two games he won like yeah
what he's trying to do steal the show
exactly next uh let's just pick up where
arena is left off Rook E1 makes a lot of
sense grab the open file Rooks love open
files B4 B7 B5 that is a a stunning move
to my eyes because arena is well again
to my eyes she's helping white uh get
rid of a week upon on A4 she traded off
but she in turn though she got a very
nice night on e4
um I'm not sure Arena did this very well
because I'm looking at this construction
of Queen and Knight I'm just ready to
take and I'm x-raying the F5 Pawn the
Knight moves I will happily take and if
you do take
this is pretty easy for white to come
out material ahead this these Rooks very
nicely everything how you protect all
this construction exactly every every
one of White's pieces is working this
Rook on A8 for arena still isn't in the
game as is white pieces please maybe
just rookie eight actually there is a
trick if you try to catch this E4 I just
take F take C4 and if you exchange all
my Rooks you will not be able to take
24. oh don't tell me pawns cannot be
captured I mean you're breaking my heart
so maybe it's enough at least two
percent
to set up for uh those eventual captures
yeah move your king as you say maybe
you're not actually threatening to do
anything there's also if I could get
some kind of King upon anything maybe
it's useful
aye I'm thinking uh Arena mistimed her
break what about Jennifer Jennifer you
she's up against Megan Lee very
important game as we have two at the top
players on the leaderboards if you will
gen Megan Lee has been playing an
excellent tournament already has played
Arena this was the scotch yes and she
decided to exchange those Bishops yes
she played Bishop B3 at certain you know
this bishop on Basics can be really
annoying so this is the idea all five is
coming yes and also if I was coming so
Bishop B3 was the idea also to push your
pawns perhaps exactly get out of the way
and that's exactly what she it and there
was a capture Bishop F5 that's a lovely
Bishop Nitro hmm that goes back
uh
I somehow that just feels a little too
compliant Knight G3 a little bit more
Bella
bellicose is needed here but Knight C3
that well okay nice she prepared to play
h3g4 so that's why black probably moved
Knight F6 H3 G4 and this night on on
um E7 needs a better job I mean that's
why I think Jennifer was making room uh
in truth truth be told actually if I was
black I'd really like to play for C6 B5
or C6 and Knight on E7 to D5 I want
pardon me let me do this again thanks to
the bishop on on G6 I would love to land
with a knight on the B4 Square from
Megan's point of view I think you yeah
said it very clearly what white wants is
you know
Pond storm you know H3 G4 F5 and if she
could you know what that's the cool
thing about this position yeah is that
you can actually play G4 right now
really without
any preparation between E2
there's two nights under under attack
right
that is actually a very picturesque
double
attacks too no not really no uh I was
trying something but it's not possible
yes no checkbook
I I I oh I feel you but the yes there is
yeah but there's an intermezza
Bishop C4 check and then I can move my
queen without fear I'm afraid it was
even Greenwich
we were close
some distance but okay if we could play
G4 and save yourself the tempo of H3
that could be very important I mean
because it basically means I can play F5
and G5 and go uh full steam ahead
actually it's really important maybe
even to explain to the viewers why it's
so important to win this right like yeah
uh well first of all whenever we have
these situations where kings are on
opposite flanks it's all about who can
get to the other king first and every
Tempo counts so move like Rook G1 if you
don't have to prepare to move G4 you
could save the Mover of G1 maybe The
Rook is better on H1 but Christian the
man of the hour darush is in-house and
we're not worthy
Darius welcome back to the studio
yesterday after a long game you came and
you said I'm very very tired right now a
pretty short game today how are you
feeling right now well definitely not
tired
no uh two more serious and more serious
nowaday I feel really really nice I feel
really really good
um yeah it was I think nice game
did you surprise you in the opening
because he was playing very very quickly
and building some sort of a Time
Advantage yeah yeah I I just wasn't sure
whether he's still in his prep or it's
some line that he prepared earlier or
because you know I I mean I played this
line long time ago so I wasn't sure
whether he would be checking my old
games because I designed 2015 or 16 I
believe
yeah yeah b3a5 here the game against
nepo like this bishop C3 yeah and then
the game was Bishop B7 knife for his
other move an id2 and he played C5 right
away in in that game and I played myself
in this version thousand I think it was
16 and it was struck Republic League uh
yeah against Bindery yeah it's here uh
down there oh yeah yeah
2016 yeah it was Czech Republic league
and I played 95. after a long game I won
uh but okay well it's probably a bit
better but yeah Queen Seven I didn't
know the move really it's of course very
logical I just
honestly like I wasn't sure what to play
with the Catalan whether to play a
ninja whether to play E4 move number
when I was choosing between the various
options I decided to play in the end
play D4 and it was one of the options I
looked at but I didn't Envision who
could play Queen C7 also got like a
bunch of ideas to play and eventually
stick with that would stick with that
one what was the type of position that
you're looking for against Hans did you
have any specifics in mind I just want
to get something playable where he
wouldn't feel so comfortable uh where I
would have a bit more knowledge but I
didn't really work out or maybe it did I
don't know it's tough to say right now
because I won pretty quickly but I don't
know where he made honestly believe me
his mistake like this seemed pretty
normal and he was playing Super yes so I
assume it was all preparation by him and
I was on my own like since Queen C7
pretty much so yeah I mean I thought
what I did was pretty standard E4 we
should be seven we should be two yeah it
makes it makes a lot of sense and okay
it's a very strange engine is like zero
zero now after if I would have played
advantage to White so I just don't
understand yeah and not only that but
after Knight C4 Queen to A8 seems to
have been quite yeah he also played very
quickly we played very quickly I was I
mean I was thinking about this move but
I was so surprised to see it because I
didn't see particularly in danger on
this diagonal of course it's logical to
line up the queen and Bishop like that
put his battery but on the other hand
like there's I couldn't see any tricks
that would actually work like okay there
is not a four trick but okay I start
with DTX C5 let's say you always have
ideas of Knight to G5 correct so
basically the xc5 and I was thinking he
used to take the pawn I really should
[ __ ] he should stick with the pawn and
now I want to play something like either
Knight D6 and 4 by 95 or something like
that or Knight d294 also I saw this idea
and I thought why is better clear here
because I get to D6 square and again
whenever he moves his knight from D5
attack on B7 over Tempo let's say for
instance Knight C3 oh it's a blunder ic3
of course but
um you know Bishop B7 is the point the
queen is hanging so that's always the
point uh so he doesn't have these jumps
right so uh but still I think what is
just better he's starting with the
Knight on C5 and I was wondering whether
I should play root takes D5 here uh I
was tempted to do this but I felt like
in the end of the day it should equalize
to roughly equal okay okay I win a pawn
but yeah it Rook C8 91 Bishop G2 King
Knight G2 and I thought he would he
would have some conversations let's have
a four or something at some point maybe
now if or even now I would think I
thought he would have some conversation
here and he doesn't yeah that's why I
didn't do that uh so that's why I was
like okay let's just go for it 96 takes
95 this looks very natural uh and yeah
actually this is already lost and by the
way he still haven't actually this was
pausing me even more this was passing me
even more it was his strategy to try to
flag me or something
maybe we try to do and Fabi did uh
but again uh this doesn't work a bit of
a recent strategy yeah with all of your
pieces attacking yeah I mean everything
is just just coming Rook C4 is very
natural I thought H7 as well yes and
it's turning King H7 Rook C4 and now
first F6 or something so now you can
check and then hear an action okay I
didn't see Ru G4 I didn't see root G4
yeah yeah I I saw that it should be
winning but I didn't just didn't like
stop calculation too early yeah I didn't
see but I thought so Rook C4 is good
enough so I just decided to play it okay
H6 yeah and Naruto rage for also I mean
Mirror May many moves are winning here
of course yeah I I didn't do it because
Queen D6 Rook H6 E5
um
okay I I just how did I wouldn't take on
D5 ah okay my God they're going to defy
everything with G6 yeah everything is
winning yeah
[Music]
um
don't forget about that yeah but 96 I
thought is just very clinical because
it's just no chance pretty much right
like Knight D6 Bishop D5 I just have
extra Pawn which is actually queening
upon all the dark squares and so on
it's collapsing Darius back to back
victories after uh the rest day what did
you do during the rest day to gain so
much confidence and
I just spent some I just spent time with
my family I guess that's the best thing
I could do and have to have some rest
for some family with my wife and family
in general so so yeah it was it that was
about it guys indeed I just uh very very
well done tip of the Hat uh impressive
attacking Victory well done darsh thank
you congratulations absolutely turning
our attention to Fabi uh versus uh
Linderman for a moment
a Fabby sacrificed upon to
make uh Black's life of what you're
going to do with your king that much
awkward we left it where you just coaxed
the weakness of B5 B4 kind of once
you've got that pawn going there you're
not castling Queen side anymore because
I can Target the A6 Pawn very nicely and
that's in fact is exactly what happened
uh Linderman actually escaped with his
King to the king Side by castling by
hand I light what both players were
doing very very much right here this
move for me was a bit of a surprise by
Fabi he's just played the move Bishop G5
more or less he wants to take and be
able to establish complete control over
the darks where something like Bishop
takes Queen E3 Knight G5 Queen F4 so
that he's always focused on the F7 Pawn
he grabbed the C file right away and for
me that's a little bit of a surprise
because if I'm in Alex's shoes I'm
probably playing the move Bishop f8 here
because right now both pieces are
wanting the square G5 can I play Bishop
F6 just to check it out sure absolutely
yeah and I'm not I don't think I'm not
I'm not taking I I probably should have
even thrown in Bishop takes D3 you're
welcome to put your knight on G5 but
then you can understand why I kept my
Bishop on f8 sometimes I can actually
play to just take the Knight and let the
bishop live so long as you don't get
your queen to H6 of course uh
on the other hand with this move Rook C1
it's very clear that what Fabby has in
mind is he does want to double Rooks
either by Rook A2 to C2 or Rook C2 and
you know take charge over the business
squares compensation yes Advantage well
uh the the judgment is still out there
and the lifetime score between these two
is I believe very uh favorable to Fabi
yes
I thought there was a number of draws
that is a good customer
Alex Lindeman probably looking at across
the board of Fabian saying why do I have
to play you a result so far yes three
results so far two decisive games linear
Domingos and sweets both of them won the
games with white pieces against the
electronic Hans and we have one job
between Christopher you and Livonia and
still four games
um in seventh round are not finished
and our Graphics department has been
working overtime we have it in graphic
form uh Lanier's win
oh
wow
[Music]
then it goes the graph goes off the
chart I like this one yes it's like we
were building the house the Empire State
Building just growing and growing nicely
done Graphics yeah everything is clear
what was happening very clear to me they
have too much time on their hands
Flynn was Graphics yes playing around
um take us to the Ray Robson game if you
don't mind a Christian because uh when
we left it Ray we thought was winning is
that still the case well uh let's take a
look he thought at this point and this
was a critical point we were discussing
he needed to find this sequence very
precise sequence of moves Bishop to H7
followed by Bishop to F5 he thought for
18 minutes and he found it he played
Bishop H7 King h8 Bishop to F5 this was
the continuation and we were discussing
this situation in which black is right
now having to defend against Bishop to
D7 it's difficult it's extremely
difficult you cannot move the Knight
anywhere else because I'm going to take
on F6 and then you're gonna get checked
made it so he played the move Knight to
E5 F4 once again trying to open up the
long diagonal Knight to G6 and moves are
coming in and they're coming in fast
Knight to G6 Knight takes F7 this is a
sign that Ray Robson actually looked at
this and analyzed this and predicted
that this is going to happen a while
back a lot of moves that go when he took
that 18 minute thing and calculated all
the variations and right now he's making
the most precise moves in the position
took a pawn back and the situation has
clarified I am going to get to your king
whether you want it or not I am going to
get to your king and this is a huge
problem in the position for black for
example if you go Queen to E7 I'm going
to go Queen to F2 so I'm starting to
look at checkmating your king the
problem is you cannot Escape if you go
to G7 I have another piece The Rook on
A1 is going to come to a G1 a lot of
checkmating threats are arising in the
position if you try to run I'm going to
bring the queen right now once again
Checkmate on h8 is coming if you go
Queen G7 I just dropped back you cannot
defend on both G and H files you don't
have enough pieces you don't have enough
momentum as black this position is
desperate right now and Ray Robson might
also be keep in contact with the Leader
by winning a second well back to back
wins for Ray Robson if he manages to
take down West you saw in this one and
he has all the chances to do so well
that would be a huge Victory indeed one
quick question for you Christian what is
what if uh Wesley goes Queen G7 in the
current position puts his Queen on H6 I
saw what you were trying to do with
Queen F2 to H4 so let me preempt you you
don't have time I go queen of five how
do you put a queen F6 is hanging if you
go Rook to f8 try defend this I'll give
you a check there's no Queen H6 right
not only that but after Rook to the G1
you're getting mated in one move well
actually sort of switch up to H7
probably right I'm just losing
everything yeah you're losing everything
right the situation is dire right now so
right I mean by looking at the position
right now and he's trying to figure out
how to save the king but there's no way
to save the king he's just busted right
now he's busted completely
well that makes it as simple as we
possibly can and uh everybody as we
prepare for a break once again we love
those questions they really put us on uh
the edge of our toes there we like uh
inviting you for the discussion we're
going to take a break Anastasia and uh
we'll see everybody on the other side
bye for now
foreign
as part of the World Chess Hall of Fame
lecture series author and international
Master John Donaldson will be doing a
live presentation on the 1972 Fisher
spasky match examining their early lives
and careers leading up to their classic
match you can join John live on October
18th at the World Chess Hall of Fame or
watch the live stream on the World Chess
Hall of Fame YouTube channel that's
October 18th John Donaldson live more
information at stlouischessclub.org
we all know St Louis is a championship
Sports Town from the 11-time world
champion Cardinals to the Stanley Cup
champion Blues
but I bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the World Chess Hall
of Fame Westport social and Topgolf and
now even our own MLS team so whatever
Sports your team is into you can always
bring out your A-game in St Louis
oops sorry St Lou is always exploring
[Music]
Welcome to our show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
.com
[Music]
founded in 1839 the University of
Missouri is steeped in Tradition the
recently founded Mizzou chess program is
a partnership between the University of
Missouri and the St Louis chess club
Collegiate Jess has been experiencing a
meteoric rise at the national level
through its tradition of Excellence
Mizzou has always strived for the best
Mizzou chess is working towards raising
the bar by bringing our institutions
ethos of respect responsibility
Discovery and Excellence to the
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
and welcome back everyone it's round
seven of us championships let's check
the results in open section first uh
Christopher you made the dragon slim one
iron and it was it was the only draw so
far right right we have to decide the
games a shocking miniature in the game
between Lanier and elshon is elshon
falls into well-known trap that game was
over in 20 minutes we barely sat down
what a terrific attacking uh game that
was and the results in the the standings
I want to ask about the ladies yes so we
have so far the same standings as we had
before
still because we don't have still
results so Arena crushed here the first
place with Jennifer you as well as Ellis
lishare the third place together with
Megan Lee
um only capable difference between them
and then we have tatio Brahman with
three and a half points and the others
as well the games are still on the way
absolutely I wanted to turn our
attention to this Clash of Giants and
Olympians if you will between Ray Robson
and Wesley so when we left it we had
seen all of this happening it was
unfolding nicely for Rey Queen F2 and
this uh I'm going to use the word naked
naked
is really about to get a lot of
attention Queen H4 check and Rook G1
Wesley said I've got to stop Queen H4 he
played the move F5 and Rey instantly
played Rook G1 and said look I'm about
to Menace Rook G5 and queen H4 and it's
going to be you know game over and
Wesley looking at the position
the bishop on B7 Rook on A8 never
participated really and Black's King is
going down this would be a huge win for
Rey as uh darush also uh will be uh plus
two lifetime score between these two
they've played each other well it's
almost even yes one win I want to say
they played 11 classical games and 10
000
games with one another They Know Each
Other Well I'm a little bit surprised by
the win loss ratio there one win uh for
uh Ray two for Wesley somehow I would
have expected that to be a more decisive
a lot a lot of draws between them Rook
G8 well this one I don't think you're
gonna ask yeah what twice
the only thing I can imagine is we gotta
get on our a walking shoes once more go
Rook G7 so the idea is that after Queen
h8 check we don't have to put our King
on G7 we can put our King on F
upon me on it so then what happens
well that's the problem uh how are we
going to follow up like Bishop H7 the
only check I can see but then king of
Fate yes nothing or F7 yes
yes
H7 you still you keep running yes and
then I don't know a queen Rook F5 yes
but keep running
right you need to take on the five maybe
there was something like Queen H6 first
I don't know if it makes any difference
okay
I do have a like like you could you you
could kind of like try try to set up
some ideas but
[Music]
there might be a check on E2 that might
be disruptive so you're trying to run
away right via E8 f8 and E8 so let's
keep going into that variation
okay so Rook G7 Queen H4 check King to
King to G8 only move yeah so now I see
your Escape path uh I'm gonna try to cut
you off with the move Queen H5 not only
that but I'm also yes yes
so how do you do it right now uh well
just show me how you oh let's say I give
you a check with H7
okay so far so good I take on F5 and you
go now I go push up G6
Bishop Jesus
oh that's beautiful and at the same time
you're keeping me at Bay with this
beautiful queen
um protection over the E2
oh that's nasty Queen H5 okay it means I
I don't have time can I
okay take a deep breath
can we have four but now I go Bishop F7
I don't think so either that's a very
nice move that Queen H5 I was wondering
if there was another move beside Rook G5
but if you can go Queen H4 and queen H5
that does the magic trick puzzle brush
yeah for Ray Russell exactly he's
counting definitely and is time a factor
I don't in race games usually it is but
in this particular game Anastasia yeah
he's doing really well because the
position became so good from from quotes
around quite a distance yes uh last
quick question Rook the G5 I know I I'm
sure I'm gonna answer it as well Rook
takes G6 Rook takes G6 dreaming wait
wait wait wait yes oops but I don't want
to take on G6 I can go Queen oh
if only yes one small step yes yes it's
not completely over but I think you take
on H5 then go King G7 but I take on F5
also and you don't have enough time to
take on C4 because of Queen to D7 so I'm
picking up everything you are all of
your parts and then I'm just going to
push my age Pawn or something like that
I think that that's a very compelling uh
Point yeah I tried Rook G7 I tried Rook
G6 but in both cases it's just not
enough wow it's looking good for Ray
guys okay and uh what about the two Sams
let's take a look what's happening
this is the current position I think we
left it off somewhere around here if I'm
not mistaken too many moves roof takes
D5 Rook takes D5 A4 makes a lot of sense
you want to open up the the a file and
activate your vipa file Knight to f8
nice move we were predicting this type
of ideas Knight to fade and try to get
the night exactly six eight takes B5
King to H2 Rook to D7 Rook to D1 Queen
to C6
black achieved whatever he wanted to
achieve and that is to get the Knight to
E6 white on the other hand hasn't
improved the position on the king side
there's no way you can invade via the
king side and take advantage of the King
on h8 I don't see Bishop D4 and any
ideas on the long diagonal happening
anytime soon so unless you have
something like E6 just sacrificed upon
and try to set something up along the
long diagonal yes I don't think but it
doesn't seem to be working because
there's no Bishop to D4 Queen you give a
check but then I just move away and
maybe bishop to E1 but
you're not in time you have your own
problems as well Bishop to D6 the port
on F4 is hanging you're not in time and
to be honest even if you are so let's
just say I'm making a random move I I
will go Queen to C8 Bishop to C3 even
this is not that conclusive there's no
immediate checks so it does look that
you have to take on F5 and hope for some
sort of a Perpetual you're not getting
to my king anytime so the Knight is an
extremely good Defender against any sort
of checks so solid position for a black
at some point I have the feeling that
white Sam Shanklin that is will have to
start thinking about uh pulling the
brakes and making a drawing this one
simplifying the position make a draw
because if you allow the Knight to E6
and then simply just the movement of the
majority on the queen side you might get
into into some strategical trouble in
this game exactly uh thank you for that
Christian for sure
um let's just jump in the game between
Rue Yang in an arena Crush when we left
it we rather like White's position right
here you had mentioned Rook ae8
Anastasia I can't trade everything off
and Munch upon on e4 at the end of all
of these trades uh you pointed out there
was a back rack made on C1 Square so we
were looking at King G1
for white we thought that white stood
better after such a move she played G2
G3 and a surprise to my eyes she decided
that this tension on e4 she wanted to
trade it off essentially giving up her
B2 bond for what I considered a weak
Pawn on F5 Queen takes E4 and Arena
immediately pounce and now played this
really powerful move Queen F2 the
problem is is White's King can easily
get checked mated like for example let
me just put a bad move on the board and
let me put a second bad move on the
board and this is what I mean by the
fact that White's King is in a little
bit of distress
ruyang played Queen C4 defending F1 but
now we can imagine for example a move
like H5 and it's very awkward for
White's Queen suddenly because the king
is really in a bad
situation right I mean you can't go
let's say Pond hunting uh something like
this would just be a suicide
um
it'll just helpful yes no hold on how
where's my mate no now that I said
suicide
okay one thing I didn't want I wanted
I wanted to follow
Queen F5 and queen G4 yes
okay that is a very pretty one thank you
Christian rescuing uh me for a moment
there so but I really like yasu like you
you spotted this King yes and
immediately you start looking for
checkmates like a pattern is here you
don't need even to know the consequences
of moves you just have a feeling that
something will be you will find
something there exactly uh that just
yeah that's just uh too much pattern
recognition that you just go bang and
instantly you understand that white is
the one in deep trouble here again I
thought Rue Yang Yan stood better when
the Rooks were on the board uh with
everything uh gone you can see that this
Pawn is actually could actually be quite
a useful decoy yes
starts running and you have some ideas
with Checkmate Maybe he's thinking about
A4 even I don't know if it works
immediately right one Queen maybe not
but I like your move I would love to set
up a situation where my king is kind of
tucked away a little bit safe uh put my
king on H6 put my Pawn on H5 later play
the move Queen to C2 so that I'm keeping
a patrol over the F5 square and then
play for A4 bottom line I wouldn't be
surprised pardon me that was just a
mouselet if this was simply winning
it is for uh Arena that would be huge
how's our young lady uh Alice Lee doing
at 12 years old she's up against
Rochelle
not amazing right now not at me I like
Rochelle's position actually well sounds
position is great yeah uh weakness that
I can play against the pawn on e4 yeah I
don't have any worries around my king
it's looking good who's ever Rochelle's
coach is like yes for sure very safe
King like the bishop on G6 good Pawn
Shield love this bishop on D4 Rook on C4
uh Alice in uh trouble in this one and
finally let's jump to Jennifer uh
uh Megan versus Jennifer because we left
it we think a really important missed
opportunity for Megan right here had she
played the move G4 with the surprising
double attack Queen E2 picking up a
piece G4 would have given her the
initiative she prefaced the attempt to
play G4 with the move Rook G1 a Tempo an
unneeded loss of a Tempo and after
Bishop F7 G3 why that's
that's I'm trying to understand why it's
still not G4 exactly that looks really
rather passive
okay I'm catching up with the players
now I think Rook takes E6 is the last
move okay I understand A4
is under attack but I also understand D6
so let's just drop the pawn
oh although that allows Knight C5
what I wanted was Knight E4 and Knight
takes A4 sorry for the fans of Sabina
fuizer a former U.S Champion not having
a good result went down once again yeah
she lost the way we're talking about
some streaky play I mean one a Sharita
started terribly like go out of three I
think she lost three of her first four
games suddenly she's the point and then
she wants three in a row nice and Serena
Crush doing incredibly well winning
three years in a row so we're seeing
some streaks yes uh going on here as
yeah I wanted to play D5 Knight E4 and
Knight takes A4 but maybe Knight C5
keeps everything intact for Megan it
defends the pawn on A4 stops 94. uh
should I capture this Pawn what do you
think yeah maybe not day four let's try
to do it I mean just maybe you can still
have something here we're Pond Grabbers
yes
your queen yes and we pick up the tempo
nice
um now what by the way Knight E4 on tap
yes so probably like if you exchange the
Queens I think it's good for black right
yeah at the moment uh
um no reason in particular that I have
to write yes you can play 95. it's it's
an intriguing uh position I'm gonna uh
throw it in Into Your Hands Christian
what do you have for us well I'm
actually looking at this game uh
developing between Guru bagintosh
because
[Laughter]
it's a wild position indeed and take a
look at this sequence Knight to E4 King
to G2 Bishop to C5 Rook to F1 and Bishop
to E7 saying okay maybe I want to take
that Knight it's uh not it's looking too
active for my taste well check this out
take it if you want Knight to G6 if you
take it I think you're going to get
checkmated Rook to F5 yeah sure you
covered uh this query H5 for my queen
I'm not checkmating you immediately but
I can preface that with a move Queen to
G4 Queen to G4 Queen to H3 you are going
to get checkmated right now so you're in
deep trouble as uh for example if you
play this move check this out Queen to
E8 Rook to h8 Queen to H3 you have to
give me everything you have right now
take King to G8 Queen to H7 King to h8
or even this nice little move Bishop to
H6 that's nasty attack flowing right now
for white of course if you take G7 G8 I
get another queen in the position and
you can pretty much resign so a very
intriguing uh set of developments in
this one
Knight to G6 was played Rook to F7 by
the way responded Queen to G4 and right
now Knight to C5 is the last move Tokyo
Nova is thinking what to do in this
position but it does seem like her
attack is devastating the bishop
probably just has to drop back could be
one it makes a lot of sense you attack
my Bishop I might as well uh drop it
back now what I'm seeing is also the
time situation six minutes for Tate with
16 moves to go that's a lot that's a lot
of moves especially when you're being
viciously attacked like she is right now
so watoh Nova should do is just not try
to find any sort of fancy responses
right now leave the bishop on D3 and
focus on the Checkmate don't go for that
just drop back the bishopone or B1 put
pressure on your opponent clock as well
as well as the position and I think she
well she has a devastating attack for
sure so you're saying no not to play
Knight takes E7
but if you drop back with the bishop
aren't you inviting uh tatev to play the
move Bishop B5 and maybe drop her bishop
and I will uh move my Rook Rook to D1
Rook to D1 okay let's say I just pause
Queen D7 let's go H6 at some point I
will break and open the position okay uh
oh dear yeah that doesn't look great
[Laughter]
um
I need I need some Knight takes E7 was
played Knight X is seven maybe let's
check this seven idea maybe she sees the
Checkmate or something I I'm sure she's
got it on her mind Bishop H7 Queen G6
I mean it looks so attractive yes if it
works then it works I'm not sure if it's
working I mean that's the question is 6
and what's your next move
well Queen G and H6 yes H6 where's the
attack
let's say Eureka five
yeah sure
if you give H7 check you just hide yes
your king gonna trade so
the attack is pretty over it's just that
the position doesn't require this type
of solutions
just how do you know you don't actually
have uh yes but what you can do and I
think this is what yeah Rook H4 is still
people keep trials Rook H4 was the idea
to play
Oh even after that you don't have an
immediate attack
even after Rook to H1 you're still not
checkmating me on the spot
so you no I'm not but let's say it's
nice a couple of pieces
especially when they're not your own but
yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean you you you
are winding up for a serious Haymaker
there yeah yeah but queen of seven
nothing goes but that was the problem
Queen F7 was and what you have to play
Queen G4 you don't really want to do
right no yes now you start to worry why
did I sacrifice a piece this one what
she's trying to do is Queen takes C7 and
Bishop to G6 Bishop to G6 ah I think
that makes much more sense than taking
on H7
so let's check it I'll confirm that very
much because in this case the open G
file plays pardon me the open H file
plays itself Rook h a check Queen H7 uh
very very well known puzzle Rush tactic
for a Checkmate but the pawn on G6 is
actually a great attacking unit so
Bishop G6 might Force you drop dash of
G5 and the queen is trapped ah well now
we understand
your student's a genius look what she
did uh takes on E7 Bishop G6 Bishop G5
coach where's my gold star don't say
that twice she will actually believe you
there's no reason to play her ego at all
absolutely
so you're from these traders who never
say to the students
you should give it work better you made
so many mistakes even though you won the
game yes it was a bad game it was really
terrible yeah I would not be proud if I
were in Europe the thing is if you look
at Bishop G6 it's not over yet no it's
not because I have ideas like Rook F5
yes okay that's fine you take my
exchange but I have the light squares
right now
I have D4 I have Bishop C6 coming I have
Knight to E6 that is true I'm seeing a
strategical uh caveat to this whole
situation for tatev right I think she's
might be feeling good if Rook to F5
comes on the board I don't think she
feels good at all but so but maybe we'll
find it because there is nothing else
actually if I was such a big threat
something about forcing moves like the
move D5 D4 you tend to spot them when
you realize that everything else is just
losing and there's also something about
French players Whenever there are light
Square Bishops correct it's like they
get a second life that's exactly right
they feel so good about their whole
situation it's like they're having a new
game a flare right so are you writing my
autobiography that's exactly how it is
for the French defense player we get
this electric jolt are you okay yes oh
yes sir yes well I I mean I wasn't only
cured after 20 years but
but I had some good moments during those
those 20 years like what you're saying
and this is exactly what she did Bishop
C6 is on the board Bishop C6
with D4 right but the same idea I will
get right it's a Telegraph and finally I
have something to play for it's like do
whatever you want on your King's side I
just finally have my Bishop into the
game
beautiful beautiful Bishop you can take
my rook and I I
like that move I mean I it certainly
Dodges Bishop G5 I mean the queen is no
longer trapped as a very nice square at
least one and many more in fact the D5
D4 yes that will be counter Spiel well
of course B5 B4 is that counters bill
that was what uh tarjan and I we would
say spiel the Spiel come on let's go
let's go Spiel the Spiel when we were
analyzing I like Bishop C6 that's a good
move yeah it's a very good move sorry
I'm not really too sure we ever came to
a conclusion about uh Megan and
Jennifer's game because it seemed like
it was really very very complex uh let's
pick it up she did by the way Jennifer
yes okay play the move D5 and after
Queen to D Ford this was a kg move night
on F6 to D7
four stalling
uh moves like Knight C5 and after Bishop
H3 Rook F6
um I want to say that White's pieces are
taking up dominant Central positions
here and wait a minute if I'm white and
I'm playing the move Rook C1 I'm getting
enthusiastic for Megan can I ask you
something please with this
90 Cent was it necessary to play I don't
know maybe 94 was possible because I
don't think the Knight is hanging or
there is some tactics here yeah I I
suppose that uh Jennifer
was worried that in some lines this
night was hanging but yes I understand
you like precisely normally you want to
centralize this is through the central
squares but you don't probably even
threat anything because like your queen
cannot really move this Knight on B6 is
always happening so you don't want to
play like Knight C4 nothing like that
exactly I'll check the time guys uh what
about the time one minute and 38 seconds
for Jennifer wow with a lot of moves to
go 16 moves to go if I'm not hold on did
you say one one minute 38 seconds oh my
goodness uh much like Ray Robson
Jennifer's kind of like uh likes that
time trouble addiction yeah but probably
doesn't like
enlightened you know that maybe every
move was like you know you need you were
not sure what's going on and you so you
kept spending time on them yes so well I
can again I'm looking at this position
and I'm saying I would really much
rather have white because again I'm
seeing some very nicely centralized
pieces Rook on A8 Knight on B6 and not
making that great impression and by the
way the queen hasn't even moved so like
what what what would you be enthusiastic
about if you were black after the move
rookie one by the way rookie one comes
with a threat of maybe playing rookie
seven so I can imagine takes okay if
Bishop takes maybe we can play Queen of
six times
good afternoon good evening yes uh King
h8 you're kind of putting your king uh
over there in the corner now here I
would like
to some way take advantage of the open
e-file I would like to do more than I'm
about to show but just for example this
idea of being able to take advantage of
the E7 Square you know if I could just
trade everything
I want more than this but but yes it
shows where the advantages for white
controlling all those squares oh my gosh
yeah that's nice yes please it seems
like Irina crushed Mr chance oh no
really yeah she did not play the move H5
actually H5 according to the engines
after a queen to C4 H5 was giving a plus
seven Advantage Plus this was it was
winning this is basically awesome you
picked up the best move in the position
in one second
what did she do instead with Queen A7
which makes a lot of sense you put a
queen behind the pawn and you just want
to promote that yeah you don't do this
you're allowing too many tracks right
now uh she started off with Queen to F4
King to E8 there's still some chances
for Irina of course this king is
probably going to go on this side and if
I manage to start pushing my Pawn you
will have some problems but it just
feels like the board is a bit
um too empty and I'm going to be able to
find that Perpetual in a lot of
instances so big chance a missed by
Irena with that move H5 Queen to A7
unfortunately through unfortunately for
Irina through her whole Advantage away
very intriguing developments in this one
two of the leaders well the co-leaders
going into this one Jennifer who is in
trouble against Megan Lee and Irina
unfortunately for her she did not manage
uh to get the decisive Advantage after
that move H5 yeah if I was in White
Shoes I'd probably play King G2 myself
yes just to get away and if you play A4
the good news after King for example
King G2 A4 the good news is that well I
can check and there's no Queen E7 yeah
you're picking up this Pawn by the way I
mean you're talking about Perpetual
checks now that my king isn't on H3 a
moment ago with my king on H3 I I was
afraid yes I fear I cannot take a disc
that I've just lost I'm not even close
to catching the pawn but with the move
King G2 well first of all I'm setting up
this and there's no cross checks the
hovering King there we go really again
wow
I think she realized you know she had
this opportunity to get out of those
mating Nets she took advantage of it
what did happen in bacon versus yeah I
was a
beg him she saw that that this bishop on
C6 was about to become a monster she put
a rook on D4 right away and maybe Tata
have missed because I will never let you
play I'm sorry I am never going to let
you play D6 if you attack The Rook with
the Knight if you got this brilliant
move Knight B3 I will play Bishop
I will not let you push the pawn any
further so what a blockade uh Christian
you should be proud okay I'm going to be
proud once uh the game is over uh but
yeah we're going to have to wait and see
how this one develops I have to say I
thought I've missed our chance also
because that moved Rook to F5 and I
think that was critical and she played
King 88 right now but doesn't that
happen you mean right here okay yeah
okay five it's mostly about the night
placement you don't have a very good
placement for the night you are looking
at E4 but I will always be able to push
it back with the move F3 right so what I
would like to go is where I would like
to go is on E6 yes yeah the Knight to E6
that will support the push with D4 as
well C6 that looks very organic yes for
a Black's position so I really like this
opportunity that she had with the move
Rook 2 F5 now we have King to h8 and by
the way what are the time uh what are
the times right now three minutes and 16
seconds for tatev
and 20 minutes I think for it looks like
four and a half minutes maybe for tatv
at this moment which is not so bad begum
has uh a lot of time 21 minutes uh she's
look she she's feeling really good what
about our our uh matchup between not
just the Sams I wanted to go to Ray
Robson and Wesley so we've been calling
this one for some time for Ray but you
still got to win it what has happened we
left it he did play Rook cheese
check and queen H5 protecting E2 Square
as you discussed as was prescribed right
Bishop went back to C8 protecting the
pawn on F5 there was a couple of uh
variations we were looking at where the
king didn't get anywhere after Rook
takes F5 so Bishop C8 makes sense Ray
says well let me take the opportunity to
pick up a pawn A5 and we're up to date
with the players how bad
that one is very very good for Ray in
fact okay it's completely winning for
okay but Lenderman just collapsed take a
look at what happened in his game Queen
to E2 uh was the move played by Fabiano
definitely putting some pressure on E6
increasing that tension Knight to E4
would have been a great move in the
position sacrifice upon but at least
after Knight takes E4 take only four
Queen takes E4 we're going to have at
this position equal pawns I understand
my king is most likely a bit weaker than
yours you have some targets but I do
have my play as well mostly related with
Rook to C3 I'm targeting this Pawn on B3
root 2 C8 is coming queen to C6 if I
manage to exchange the Queens got it
then this one is probably going to be a
draw right exactly so big moment and big
opportunity and check this move out king
to G8 say what
this is a very strange move to my eyes
because yeah the geometry of Queen takes
E6 which
it take and take on A5 not only that
and then you take with exercise you're
getting checkmated yes one one check
first of all I can also take your Rook
but I don't have to I go here I go here
I get the Knight to D6 and this one is
going to uh and in pain for uh at the
black team so unfortunately you cannot
do that but what else what are you going
to do as black because if you try to go
Knight to E4 yeah I have this move
please the queen on E2 is so well placed
he played rookie eight in the game
rookie eight sure but Rook A6 it's same
same story why not absolutely you take
on D4 I take on E6
you're getting completely destroyed oh
that's terrible I'm invading right now
and there's absolutely no counter
chances uh coming on the king side like
a big opportunity
yes this is important for Fabiano right
because Ray is winning his games yeah
not only that but she's coming from
behind right yeah he was minus one
he's like oh my gosh
root takes yeah and especially in that
moment when he did play King G8 because
two very decent Alternatives were on tap
first of all I love the move Knight E4 I
mean just break up this very powerful
knight and queen combination I love that
move but
you know even excuse me that was a mouse
but even the move Rook C3
is a much better alternative than King
to G8 King G8 not only blenders upon it
doesn't even the worst possible fashion
if the Knight was on e4 you know you
would be playing 19. it'd be a different
different story altogether blunders upon
and gives white additional momentum to
develop the attack Rook E8 on the board
um
Fabi just kind of like
re-orienting himself counting His
blessings right now exactly exactly five
yes no but these mistakes they come
usually when you are under huge pressure
and this is what probably was happening
with Alex like you know to play against
Fabi every move you have to watch out
all these ideas of your opponent yes you
know you your oppona but European has
initiative so probably he just
completely forgot about this option Rook
A5 and misplayed and also uh it seems
like Fabiano has his number
it's very difficult to play against
these players of course if you yeah it's
it's another story it's true uh did you
have any of those type of players that
you were just either winning against or
losing oh my goodness absolutely
absolutely yes uh I would always be
player a who would always be player B
who would always be player C who would
always beat me there was like this uh
death Loop and yeah I mean I had a great
score I was 4-0 against Michael Tall
yeah exactly right and uh there was a
guy Michael Michael what
and there was there was a guy uh uh
there was a guy off Anderson
I joke with off that if I ever wrote a
book my my best games it would be you
know like the eight games that we played
you know the whole book uh oh I I only
beat off once in classical uh games but
I mean every game he beat me and I think
he beat me like five times was like
masterful like just you could learn so
much uh from those games
compete with the wisdom right Peter
biasa started a 6-0 against me before I
started beating Peter it was like Walter
Brown and so on yeah but it's usually I
was able to write the ship but boy there
were some players I just couldn't you
know compete it was pretty strange uh
foreign
is one of those guys that I can just
simply not compete against yeah I beat
him the first time
um and after that I lost seven times in
a row it's just so difficult for me to
play against Ray I don't know he has
this uh manner about his style of play
and his style of focus all the time he
seems like a baby assassin maybe faced
assassin the baby takes assassin he's
not always so focused he uh doesn't show
any emotion he rarely gets uh off the
board he's always there in your face and
I I really despise that yeah I like him
as a person I love rape but playing
against him is not easy there was a
brilliant Randy uh singtel and Kevin
have made This brilliant uh it was 60
minute
documentary of 10 years years chess club
in St Louis and showing over the years
how it evolved one of the things about
that documentary which is so funny is
Ray Robson really yeah because he was
like in the first U.S Championship as
like a kind of gawky 14 year old we saw
we see him 10 years later and he's grown
like three feet exactly and
Ray has been a fixture here in St Louis
I saw I saw him emotionally when we
played Buck house chess then he gets
upset with my place
[Laughter]
sometimes it was really funny but no
actually he's like just calm down keep
playing yeah
speaking of Ray he's putting the
finishing touches on yeah
seven or something right let's jump to
that game of uh and him drinking water
is a bad sign yeah he's just relaxed you
know hey come on it's time to get out
okay so like the whole point is like we
cannot walk into a discovery check that
displays itself we can't go to F7 that
will hang The Rook so our move is Force
King f8 and then you were saying Bishop
takes
whatever's on the board Rook to G2 is on
the board
so that's the point you cover the second
rank first
nice quiet move very nice yes yes I'm
telling you he's the baby face assassin
he sees everything I'm sure about that
yes okay
ah D6 is hanging so if I try to just
stop you from taking the pawn on F5
um
could this be a zoo song it looks like
oh my gosh not only that not only that
but I think uh the geometry Works in
White's favor for example Queen F7 yeah
just D6 Queen E7 just to say once again
the king is frozen any King moves cost
you The Rook so we remove the queen but
we cast the pawn queen no I can even
take on E7
oh my gosh
and there goes the bishop King F7 I take
the bishop and you cannot take my Bishop
because the king is in front
so that's unfair
okay so uh no Queen no no Queen moves no
Rook moves no King moves so before I
think these might just be we just take
on the phone resignation time why we
take on the five and then Queen that's
the whole point I think yes that's the
plan oh nice Anastasia you're a very I
was asking myself this question
look at this bishop if I was working
because the Christian mentioned it and I
was asking myself is it working but then
I found this clinic and it's even mate
it's just simply mate King F6 you don't
even take my queen yes you just
brutalize nice nice uh Rook E2 that is a
quiet killer a rook G2 pardon me that is
really
wow that's the Finishing Touch we're
actually trying to see a resignation now
unless maybe you can still try Bishop B7
Bishop uh the idea is that in this case
I can uh cover G8 by a miracle
oh here I can actually even play Rook G8
but the whole point of Bishop takes D5
was to have that defensive opportunity
or not okay so Bishop B7 can we do worse
damage
then I think we can take we can take on
G7 just the simple taking on G7 and
queen takes D6 no no after Bishop 5. oh
with or without well because this is
also kind of attractive right you have
to play here yeah and then I go here
yeah
and then I don't I mate you you have to
go Queenie that's yes but you cannot
take on B7 because I'm giving you some
checks right I can't uh you might Escape
but
um
maybe you get the Perpetual you're right
you definitely don't want to calculate
that no but I think you can take on F5
first all right take on D5 D5
ah and my queen this comes back to G2
that's much cleaner I like it yes yes
that is much much much nicer and you can
as you say any checks your queen can
always interpose on G2 that seems to be
it guys wow
and again we're seeing some streaks uh
again darush played a marvelous game
today
um
Fabiano
it's kind of uh on a street but Rey uh
we were talking about how many players
were you know five draws in a row in the
first half as sometimes you can't do
anything but draw and then suddenly
we're seeing all of these wins in a row
and the defending Champion Wesley so
um
not enjoying uh this moment what is
happening between the two youths uh
Jeffrey Zhang and a Wonder Liang for a
long time we thought that game was going
to be a draw is that still the case I
think so yes I think that is still
indeed the case because we have this end
game it doesn't seem like well Shirley
is white who is pressing of course
um but how you how do you make a lot of
progress in the position because if you
do go Rook to A7 I think I'm going to go
King to G5 right
and it's all about this move H4 that I
want to play and exchange some parts
like for example if you go B4 or A4 I
think I can go H4 well A4
no what am I saying it's not pinned
H4 yeah
and then you can go Rook check though
right but then I go King H6
and Ray Robson has won the game what a
game though
uh position
wow really great plate and a really
really great game sometimes you just tip
your hat and what a different
What A Difference A Day Makes I came on
the show we came on the show and we were
reveling over the fact that in round six
of the decisive games were won by black
six out of the seven pardon me decisive
games were worn by black I'm looking now
at the men's section I'm seeing a
whitewash Ray just won and we're
expecting fobby just moves away from
winning and again the results Anastasia
speak for themselves exactly victories
for white pieces so linear Rey and that
is all of them the one with white pieces
Bobby to win as well to join the party
there
the white piece is fun uh Sam Shanklin
Sam sevillan uh Bishops of opposite
color but okay I I much prefer uh
Black's position in this one I mean
probably a draw but this Pawn is much
more dangerous than this spawn which is
heavily blockaded and uh G1 is an is a
potential entry square and I think we
should just stay with the Fabiano game
right now for sure I think we're going
to see a resignation very soon Rook to
G5 came to h8 and I think the easy way
is to just go Queenie two
threaten Queen H5 and then Force the
queen trade with Queen F3 going into a
very easily technical winning end game
exactly
yeah
position just collapsed yes for relics
King to G8 yeah and for those of you
just uh put it on my board right right
here we were expecting uh two very
decent moves the most natural is to
return the pawn 94 trade off this very
powerful attacking night and go into a
major ending where you have the move
Rook C3 and the game roughly speaking
equal even or if you don't like those
apples just post up with Rooks to C3
instead the worst of all worlds he's
dropped back with his King and allowed
this sham sacrifice of The Rook
uh you can't take the Rook Queen takes
E6
thank you for putting your King on G8
yes uh I will win uh Back The Rook as
well and then after rookie eight Rook A6
it was all she wrote as
um
well uh Fabi has gained a lot of Pawns
and he did oh I don't know if he did
play we do have him wait they took Queen
F3 Queen takes F3 he takes F3 and we
have Rook ending with two extra pawns
for white that sounds I think the way it
sounds like it and maybe even enough
maybe potentially because this F3 is
weak or before as well yeah really hard
to do something exactly he's going to go
to C8 and try to get the F2 Pawn but
that's not going to be enough I'm going
to go Rook G3
I don't know if you want to do that
three against the one I think just Rook
B5 I kind of do actually
I kind of just yeah of course
I'll put the Rook on the seventh Rank
and wait for this Rook to move wherever
The Rook goes you'll either uh toss away
the B4 Pawn or you'll toss away the F3
Pawn okay and he did play Rook C8 I
think the easiest He suggests go root G4
yeah
yep you're uh from your lips to
to fabby's ears Rook to G4 Rook C2 I
take the B4 Pawn I I don't want to worry
about that pawn at all
and then after you take on f2i now I go
King G4
oops excuse me King G4 King G4 Rook F4 I
agree that makes perfect sense to me too
Christian and uh once you play uh the
pawn on F2 I go King F3 and then we will
study at the same position
against and Rook against Rook it was
like yesterday we checked it with uh
Livonia and against
no no no no no Anastasia no I'm being
cruel here I'm going to go yeah
no you don't want to check the sentence
yeah
there you go wow won her game again
Victor with the white pieces here
as tatv is having quite the roller
coaster tournament yeah she lost three
games in a row actually it's a third one
I think wow if I'm not mistaken yes wow
and I think
the same idea that you're having a
Christian is uh just
keep all the pawns exactly the moment
you play F3 F2 I'm gonna go King F3 in
the meanwhile I'll Rush the B Pawn of
the board which is exactly what Fabi has
done I know my guy he's very cruel he's
a very cruel guy he's not going to give
you any chance right any hopes
and he's and he's gonna go be sexy
Rook b a check and B7 then he's going to
be threatening to give away the rook and
force you to play Rook B8 correct yeah
there will be one and then he will take
your phone exactly
Alex is just going through the motions
here he wants to show the whole world
why he is about to resign and that will
mean we only have two games uh left in
the open section Jeffrey Zhang versus a
Wonder Liang again we think is a draw
yes and the two Sams also playing for
Sam's Supremacy
B7 yes
of course and now rugby one you have to
try ff2 right um well Rook GA check
though Ah that's a problem
you don't have this you don't even have
you don't even get a try you you just
play Rook B1 and go three pawns down and
uh that's it yeah and wait for your
opponent to push the pawns is that it
yeah so the idea is after Rook B1 King
takes F3 then we're just going to push
our pawns until we can move our Rook
with a check and promote the pawn uh
yeah well done Tabby yes
um he keeps his one point lead and by
the way guys Jennifer you is in big
trouble right now yeah we felt that it's
it's not going really great especially
with one minute on her cloak
so what's what happened at the end all
pieces it's minor piece okay she did
she did whoa whoa she's not happy uh
Megan said wait a minute you know what
if I've got control of the e-file I'm
not going to let you trade off any of
the Rooks I'll drop my Rook back rookie
seven rookie one keeping all the Rooks
on the board
C5 Queen F2 D4
I must say Megan is playing incredibly
well I love how she's keeping control
throughout the whole game
after after winning a pawn
then she traded down everything and this
resulting ending is not even close
the king is far away far away whereas
White's King is right there in the
action she's going to go King takes E2
King D3 and by the way if she ever needs
it she is the one that can create a have
passed Apon Knights hate dealing with
that this is over this is being close
you're absolutely right I wouldn't call
it over yet there's still a technical
task what's the trick but it shouldn't
be a difficult technical thing she
played King ga yeah King G8 so inviting
yes but now if you take I can go Knight
D5 and maybe set the Knight on B4 and
dream of some sort of uh a fortress yeah
it makes
yeah it makes sense because a moment I
was just about to play B3 B4 exactly but
Knight D5 that makes I'm just dreaming
no no no no but it's a good dream I I
would prefer not to allow the Knight to
take that
almost I want to say Fortress like
square that is a zombie foreign
and I am dreaming of taking playing the
move before and getting my outside past
a pawn going
um and if I if I ever Force this I am uh
Too Close Jennifer body posture says it
all she is not happy camper uh we did
shall I just look at Alice Lee for a
moment she is suffering upon down major
peace ending
okay but because of the reduced yeah
because of the heavily reduced material
some hopes to make a draw here and
finally uh where is Arena Crush against
Rue Yang Yang
um wow extra Pawn
for uh Arena uh
but uh back over to you Christian with
Gaston Studio we are indeed with Google
nova after an important Victory against
welcome back to the show how are you
feeling what are your initial feelings
after this game
um I'm feeling all right thought of this
uh she's a very good friend of mine
that's why it's kind of like sad we had
to play
so that's why I feel just sad that I
meet my friends and you guys also did
some training together in preparation
for the Olympia so you guys know each
other yeah right yeah yeah and then
we probably both expected that this
opening is gonna happen so it wasn't
such a big surprise for her or for me we
just got a playable position and I don't
know at some point she just made not the
best moves let's go through the game so
E46 status does uh play the French for
the most part C6 Knight to C6 and Bishop
to D7 Bishop to E2 Knight to E7 i283
explained was this position well
actually I forgot to check Knight E7
immediately I was uh before the game I
forget for some reason I checked lines
after ctxd only see text T and after
that right a different moves yeah Knight
is um but still I have a I have an idea
a night day two night C2 because uh
Knight on C2 is protecting D4 pawn my
Center is stronger and I can try to like
attack on the king side after and it
seems like this is the type of position
that both of you were willing to accept
G3 I think uh she needs to put the
Knight on a F5 not G6 but there is a
line with 96 as well but I didn't
remember like I think Knight F5 is
better a night to see two yeah it's just
a line right 96 also a line but I have a
feeling that it's just worse for uh
black after g3h4 perhaps specifically
because what uh you did with g3h4 tried
to create some problems for the Knight
on juice H4 would be better like after I
played Knight C2 I I was like I had to
just push H4 immediately
yeah that would create more problems for
her that makes sense but you play Knight
C2 and still it does seem like you have
some time to prepare your expansion
right I mean yeah this is the only line
that can happen all right later H5
Knight to h8 and here he played this
move Bishop to F4 I'm sure sure it feels
like I'm putting some pressure on uh
black center and the King side but like
I couldn't see how I can like improve
the position so I decided to develop as
my coach mentioned
I remember our talks yeah yeah I just
decided to develop I was like okay
speaking of development how about you
finish with a castle I don't wanna I
didn't want to I guess so I wanted to
play King F1 and King G2 but
yeah I thought
I thought on H1 is better than on the
phone and you don't develop too much
yeah it will be too much okay so you
played Bishop D3 maybe Queen B6 would be
interesting move for her I didn't see
that and while she was thinking I
realized after Queen B6 I still have to
Castle if I don't do it her idea is to
take on E5 so for example if you go no
yeah if I do that like I'm still
protecting against that I was going to
play Queen E2 anyways but like if I try
to do something on this side like yeah
and no Petri maybe like B3 yeah the idea
is that E5 is hanging you just take on
E5 and then suddenly it's just check my
internet too there's this idea yes yeah
they take and now Checkmate on F2 yeah
okay very interesting idea I thought
maybe she can get something after Queen
B6 but I'm not sure but she decided to
go yeah which is a good move
and at this point you started spending a
little bit of time and you came up with
this idea of night to age okay I was so
surprised I was like okay it felt like I
had something but like uh and I just
just started to realize I missed
everything that I had and I was like I
can exchange and play a cool position or
I can try something because she didn't
have much time so
I've got 27 minutes at this point for
her and one hour and four minutes for
yourself I didn't see what she can play
here it seems like Knight to E4 would
have been the right move
I don't think you can take if you take
take take after Queen to A5 or queen yes
it seems like uh
yeah usually that would be better than
what she did right yes because my king
is worse here than F1 her pieces are
very centralized and you don't have time
to Castle because of Bishop takes H4 and
actually after Knight to E4 Bishop takes
H4 or Rook takes F4 is a big question
looks better that's why I didn't want to
play Knight H4 I fought with myself
there like I was like Knight H4
shouldn't be right and you are looking
at ideas of Knight G6 yeah and trying to
sacrifice something because if I'm gonna
like exchange the pieces it's so easy
for her to play so I I thought maybe I
really do have something so I just
played Knight H4 but I didn't realize
after Knight E4 I was just like
got it got it and after that this was uh
the critical moment right here after she
allowed you to get the Rook on D4 very
nicely uh Place Yasser was very happy to
see that nice blockading look on uh D4
uh begging congratulations and important
victory for you we'll see you in the
rest of your games oh congratulations
indeed big events we see that in the
ladies section no draws everybody is
swinging for defenses three decisive uh
games well let's take a look at the
results and see for ourselves Anastasia
we just saw the game and Sophia won
again lost against Nazi by kizuki this
result with this game we almost didn't
pay enough attention to Alice Lee
against Rochelle
Alice upon down in a queen and pawn
ending she's doing her best uh so he's
also trying to survive yes exactly
Jennifer is also trying to survive and I
think she went for that
yeah and by the way results in the open
section yeah we have more results here
it's five games are over for sure yes
and two games only remained uh four
decides the results out of five only one
draw between Christopher you and Leon
aronian and all the other games white
one Fabiano linear Ray and Darius all of
them defeated their opponents today
wonderful uh real whitewash going on
there and Christian with guests in
studio I'm indeed with Ray Robson
back-to-back victory for you Ray and a
big one against Wesley what are your
initial feelings right now
yeah I'm
feel like I would expect to be like more
joyous I'm very happy but yeah I'm a
little bit surprised I guess how well
the game went for me uh I've played
Wesley many many times I think probably
our last like
I don't know eight games or something
have been draws usually when I'm I've
been white many times and I usually get
zero Advantage I just have to
immediately make a draw so today went a
lot differently we were looking at your
head to head and I think he was leading
two victories to a one and eight draws
so it was very very combative within
between YouTube and you guys know each
other from college days how would you
assess Wesley as a trustler what are his
strengths weaknesses
um well he's give us some insights
obviously he's he's good at everything
he's a universal player I guess more
positional
um in general but obviously he can
attack
um yeah he studies a lot he reviews his
lines all the time
um but he probably wasn't expecting that
I would know this line that we had today
and he is he can be a concrete player if
he thinks the position is good even if
it looks risky he may just go for it
um so sometimes he might be susceptible
to attacks which I guess is uh did you
know this line uh the spawn sacrifice
yeah so I was it's not super common line
but fortunately I recently had reviewed
this line so uh I was pleasantly
surprised to see it
um and then you have to take take
um I believe yeah H3 is a interesting
move preventing Bishop G4 and after
Knight bd7
um I think Queen C2 okay apparently
there's one game but I think it hasn't
really been analyzed much the idea is
you're just delaying the development of
the bishop
um if White had played Bishop B2 I think
D5 is supposed to be the correct
response for black
um whereas keeping the bishop there one
move longer means the bishop might go to
G5 in some lines I think here D5 just is
losing for black maybe bishop A3 or
something
in fact let's check that yes the engine
confirms Bishop to A3 or Bishop to G5
seem to be very very strong actually
Bishop to A3 root to E1 Rook to E7 oh
this should be seven yeah or Bishop he
said that's a problem yeah yeah so B6 I
remember is uh yeah a move and okay
Bishop B2 Bishop B7
um D5 yeah actually in this position
still so you are still within your
preparation at this point I mean I had
to analyzed this previously yeah
um and yeah basically I knew my idea is
if he plays something similar to what he
did in the game with the queen f8 then I
can go for G4 King H2 G5 and just attack
um
and that was basically all I knew so
yeah he played C6 here uh which I didn't
remember from my analysis so I was
hoping it would be a mistake apparently
it is apparently it is it is and
especially with the moves that you found
over the board take us through your
thought process at this point because
you only have one path and you have to
be extremely precise you thought for 18
minutes what were you thinking about
yeah what were you calculating I'm a
little bit surprised there's only one
win here I mean it looks overwhelming
for example Rook G1 is a very natural
move as well
um yeah he can put the the queen on E7
in general I wasn't sure yet to give the
Fate score for his King I mean
going back to CD I was
um immediately drawn to this idea of
Bishop H7 Bishop 5 where Bishop F5
immediately but Bishop H7 felt a little
bit better forced him onto the long
diagonal where my Bishop is and also his
King can't uh run away to the queen side
as quickly so this felt very natural but
um there are a couple of things so after
King HD Bishop F5 I'm just starting to
take so 95 looks kind of forced F4 and
one option was Knight takes D4
yeah and now after Bishop F6 gf6 if
Black's King were back on G8 I assume
it's completely crushing even just Rook
G1 here I was uh took me a while to find
the way because Rook G1 I'm a Tempo down
so I wasn't sure if it was working
apparently it's still working but uh I
hadn't calculated deep enough to be sure
about that but then I noticed I have
Queen E2 and he doesn't have Queen H6
ever because Knight F7 and FG Queen H5
is just made so once I noticed this
queen queen E2 Queen H5 is always
working
um I became very happy so then I was
about to play this and then I realized
okay I should check Knight G6 one more
time after F4
Knight G6 and initially I intuitively
just felt completely winning but then
when I was calculating
I couldn't see like a clear win like if
I take on G6 F6 G6 Queen takes G6 I
thought he has Queen E8 and somehow he's
just holding so I could play after
Knight G6 Rook G1
which maybe is yeah okay apparently it's
also crushing but
I wasn't completely sure and then
I started calculating what I did in the
game Bishop F6 GF Knight F7 queen of
seven Bishop G6 and I saw okay I'm only
done one Pawn his King's completely open
g-files open Queen's gonna go with F2 H4
F5 H5 and I didn't see any way he could
organize his pieces in time so I decided
this should just be winning and that's
when I played Bishop H7 Bishop five yeah
and your intuition was definitely
correct because he's just one tempo of
short yeah so actually it's interesting
after Queen E7 if he could just yes back
there I thought the game is just over I
mean I thought Queen F2 was crushing um
but I just for some reason uh missed F5
which is the only try and then yeah
after Rook G1 okay I thought it's still
just completely game over but I missed
the Rook to G7 and his King somehow has
a shield and I can't attack and then I
became worried that somehow I've just
messed it up because it must have been I
knew I must have been winning
um but then I think yeah I was fortunate
this queen H5 so Queen H4 King G8 Queen
H5 and the point is if D takes C4
um Bishop H7 King f8 Rook takes F5 Rook
F7 and initially they only saw Queen H6
King 8 Bishop G6 but then he should give
checks and make a Perpetual or maybe
check maybe
um but after Rook F7 there
I moved yeah after 33 Rook F7 I want to
move back yeah I I noticed that Bishop
G6 finally yeah so he doesn't have time
to take on C4 he has to go back and then
CD and E2 is covered E2 is covered and
still I had to find the Breakthrough but
then I realized I can do what I did in
the game just put the queen on H6 Rook
on G2 and then I'm always turning Bishop
F5 and he just he can't move any any
pieces um if he plays like Bishop B7 in
the final position Bishop takes F5 I
thought it's the simplistic Rook G7 and
then I take on D6 take on D5 and queen
comes back to G2 and
I'm gonna set up a piece so Ray
congratulations uh big victory for you
guys any questions yeah first of all
congratulations Ray you started with
five draws uh you can't you you couldn't
win a game and uh suddenly uh the clouds
parted the sun is shining what happened
oh I don't know yeah I'm very surprised
like obviously I was playing Hans
yesterday and then Wesley today so still
two super strong opponents and was
definitely was never expecting to get
two wins
um I don't know yesterday I think Hans
was just
um a bit over aggressive at the critical
moment and today uh I think today
obviously I got lucky that he played
into this very dangerous line which I
happened to study recently so yeah I
mean I played well both games but I
think I've been playing pretty well
throughout the tournament just uh maybe
my opponents gave me a few more chances
and uh yeah I was I was ready to pounce
yeah yes sir you you met Yasser actually
mentioned today that you live together
with uh Wesley and you played thousands
of games of blades like and do you think
you actually get something from uh
Wesley and his style while you were
playing all these games and uh did you
did you cooperate with him after you
stopped the college and uh later on
yeah I mean we worked a bit together
when we were at Webster but mostly it
was him you know he that's when he kind
of started to be really serious about
Chess and started his Ascension um so he
was studying all the time
um and I I was not at that point so
occasionally like I would join him and
analyze some things but mostly it was
just him on his own um as far as playing
with him if that helped me uh definitely
helped me a lot I would say that's
almost the only reason I improved
um when I was in college is just through
being around him playing against him
asking him questions about certain types
of positions I once I realized that he
was actually just a much better player
than me I started listing to what he was
saying and uh I think it changed the way
I thought about Chess so
um you know I think I went from 2600 to
about 26 50 at that time and I think
primarily that's just because of
learning from him wow that's really nice
I mean that's really impressive and
today you even managed to win I think it
even feels really good today okay
congratulations once again yeah very
nicely done indeed Ray you still got a
second half of a tournament to go but it
feels good to be doing it with a plus
two and undefeated escort let's just
jump in into uh the game between Jeffrey
uh Jean and the Wonder Liang we've been
thinking that that was a draw for some
time uh Anastasia and yeah the players
have been repeating their moves and I
see you wonder is actually double
checking a score sheet to ask himself
are we at a seven a pardon me seven move
repetition three
three move uh repetition or not uh we do
expect that uh game to be drawn and then
we have the two Sams playing Christian
over to you
we are indeed with the men of the hour
uh the leader in the open section
Fabiano caruana Fabi welcome back to the
show you're coming quite often uh to our
show that's the only reason he wins yes
oh it seems like you want to see us
we're doing a lot of shows together
recently that is true we see each other
quite often tell us about this game
actually first of all tell us about this
game the one between Lanier and elshon
because it finished in 20 minutes were
you completely shocked was it actually
20 minutes yes maybe I saw this comments
when he when he castled after C4 because
this was played before this whole game
this was played in a high level game I
think it was like Grisha Duda
really really
I I don't see it like the way that
like after Bishop takes E4 this this
happens in some like online rapid game
okay yes probably rapid yeah yeah maybe
it's not not there but this was
definitely played I mean it's a trap
like you're supposed to play DC4 here
yes it's uh I played well you know we
prepared this line for the 2018 World
Championship so I played this quite a
lot with black and um the areas like
Bishop C4 Castle rookie 1 Knight C6
D5 and Knight B8 I think I played like
this against Hare Krishna uh
but yeah I mean after once he played
Castle I'm like I know exactly what's
going to happen next so you were looking
at this game and you were already
pre-facing what's going to happen I I
didn't want to look
it's like it's like watching a car crash
in slow motion when when he plays Castle
and and you know exactly that he missed
it's a bit of a surprise that Bishop
before but I mean if you play this
opening you should know the basic tricks
about it and I think this was uh the
caveat he played perhaps for the first
time this opening uh now let's talk
about your why against I understand it's
a great opening the petrol but why
against Lanier an expert in the past
linear is like the biggest expert in the
world on the petrol it's even if you
don't lose in 10 moves it's still a
strange choice but okay yeah it's uh
accidents happen difficult game indeed
and you started with this intriguing
Queen to C2 followed by E4 as well and
it seemed like you surprised your
opponent early on how did you come up
with this idea well I saw that Alex
played this earlier in the tournament
DC4 so I thought maybe he prepared the
slavin specifically this line for the
tournament and I remembered that when I
Was preparing this opening for black in
2020 for the candidates that this E4
line was very dangerous and later on
Perugia played it against me and it was
a very dangerous position I thought so I
thought okay this will be an interesting
try
um it was interesting because he
actually approached the position the
same way I did against Perugia yes well
like Bishop D3 A5 is
is probably the best move to get Knight
A6 quickly and a mess begins
uh but he played A6 and I was a bit
surprised I didn't expect that he would
go for okay we transpose later
um
to my game against Perugia like after
Rook D1 H6 I think we transposed
yes yeah so we got a different move
order I couldn't remember exactly how
but I remembered that he played H3 here
with the idea of Bishop E3 yes and this
was like an online game during the
pandemic and uh and I remember that this
this plan of Queen E2 to bring the queen
later to G4 was the most dangerous way
so you've analyzed that game against
firoza like two years ago
um so I I kind of remembered some of the
ideas but I definitely messed it up very
quickly like I I think this 91 was
probably good
uh Queen B6 is very natural yeah I
wasn't sure Queen G4 Bishop P3 first but
let's say queen G4 G6 and yeah here I
was hesitating like Bishop B3 I was
worried that he'll get an I'd be Aiden
and I didn't want to allow this Knight
B8 and Knight C6 but maybe the Knight
ends up being very poorly placed there
which is what I realized later but the
position was like a bit of a mystery to
me I was trying to understand it he was
playing very quickly and I started to
feel under pressure and I don't really
understand the position well enough and
uh
and so I wanted to stop his uh his IBA
that's why I played Bishop D2
I was thinking he would play A5 and I
would play uh and the Ada if he goes
Knight to B8 Bishop yeah I hear those
Bishop 35. so B4 A5 was very natural and
I was thinking at least now his his
Knight can't get to B8 to deep to B4 but
then I realized that I don't really have
an easy way to continue to play like his
King is stuck in the center yeah but
eventually it might get to the king side
and
yeah I wasn't too happy with with how it
turned out
so then we got I mean I think it was
about equal always I was a bit more
happy with my position than than his
would say at this point
how did you assess the position at this
point I was happy here but still I was
low on time and not exactly sure so I
played a bit
probably a bit um
too slowly and not concretely enough and
you could even say like a little bit um
possibly but still there are a lot of
things happening around the king side
you have ideas of Queen to F3 put a lot
of pressure on F7 and then this moment
came you took Queen to E2 yeah I mean
it's just very very silly because it was
a normalish game
complicated position I thought we both
played normally maybe not great but
normally and then just like
an absurd blender I didn't understand
even what the point was and he thought
for like 13 minutes at this point what
was your reaction when you saw him
touching the king and going for King to
dream I hadn't even considered this move
in advance because it looks terrible you
you lose the loose and I don't have six
and then like within a second I saw that
you can take and play Rook A5 I was
thinking one two options of his were one
was this Rook C3 it's very strange Queen
E5 Queen B8
and I was going to play Rook C3 because
if I take on E6 surprisingly I think
it's a mistake King F7 Knight G5 King G7
and then games are probably a draw but I
have Rook C3 BC
um Queen E3
and like let's say he has no easy way to
defend this Pawn let's say queen B3 or
K5 once my Rook gets in the game the
attack is tremendous so uh so this I was
happy with but I thought maybe after
Queen 294
after uh I thought I would be better but
in the game yes 94 take take and then he
has Rook C3 in that this is a crucial
idea
and here I was looking at Queen E5 King
I wasn't sure where let's say yeah take
take and Rook A5
uh C2 Rook C5
yeah Rook see it I mean it's it's
holding on Holding On by
only this detail okay yeah so here I
lose here I lose against the Palm yeah
so that's why his King goes to H7 not G8
because otherwise with the King on G8
there's it's a check that makes sense so
here if you go King to G80 yeah here
same line
or maybe he has
there's no more but he has worked here
instead of
yeah okay
uh anyway black is the one who has to
calculate this to a draw so
I wasn't enormously worried but King
James just uh
very bad mistake Fabiano uh first of all
congratulations uh you are winning game
after game but also your competitors are
coming from behind especially Ray Robson
what is your take on Rey's result
oh I think he played a great game today
I mean I I didn't check the game but uh
it looked like he had a very strong
initiative from the opening up dog
Wesley played this very risky line
it seemed like Ray knew it quite well
and uh
I don't know if he was like always much
better but it looked like Wesley was
under pressure so so yeah Ray is playing
very well um I don't know who else is uh
nobody else is on plus two right no
Darius is on plus one but
is
uh and a wonder is losing to Jeffrey
right so Jeffrey goes on plus one is
that correct I wonder uh made the draw
against Jeffrey
yeah it's still a long way to go but the
last few days have been good guys and
indeed the Fabi just keep it up it's a
pleasure watching you play in great form
and uh right now you're on a roll so do
enjoy yourself uh I was one it was a lot
of fun I was actually wondering that of
Fabiano has this great score we remember
we were discussing that he has this
fantastic score against Alexander and is
it helping I mean is it helpful when you
know that your opponent doing really
badly with you I mean have you thought
about it I think it puts a lot of
pressure on on the other guy who doesn't
have a good score so it does get in your
head if you're consistently playing
poorly against someone uh so yeah
against Alex um
I've had a really good score the last
few years
we've only really played in the US
Championship but I've won every game so
maybe maybe that also contributed to
when he started to feel Under Pressure
then it put him under a bit more
psychological pressure
yeah exactly and I thought also we were
discussing today about the different
approaches are you concentrated on your
game only and try not to really check
the games of the others or you really
like to walk around and check what's
going on no I check all the games I mean
today was impossible not to you know but
it looked like I mean it was a very
bloody day wasn't it yes yes Hans lost
it seemed like he got a very bad
position from the opening
uh Wesley losing is a really big result
yeah five decides of games I think so
far yes well I guess I guess Sam against
Sam will be a draw
foreign
[Music]
so they're both playing solidly I guess
they're uh
they're playing decently fifty percent
right
plus one yeah so he's having a pretty
good tournament yeah yeah okay full
control over the all boards it sounds
like yes thank you the Curious mind uh
and again very very well done I do keep
up the good work and let's take a look
at the results by the way yes so first
of all women we have a three decisive
games at at least
and also Sophia lost against Nazi by
kids and we have two draws but we really
are expecting that Megan will win
against our code leader Jennifer you and
that will be a huge result for Megan Lee
you see
in the open section what are the results
there yes and in the open section we
have the only game which is left between
two sims is still it's still gone going
but uh
look at this the white pieces
all of them scored with white pieces and
two drawers between Christopher you live
on aronian and Jeff drunk and a Wonder
yank
able and we have a guest in studio with
Christian we are indeed with Nazi
paikiza after her first Victory here at
the USS Championship with Nazi welcome
to the show congratulations it's been a
difficult event for you up to this point
how important was for you to win this
game thank you Christian it's really
good to be here
um yeah I had a really rough start there
were at least two games where I was very
close to winning and in time Scrabble
didn't manage to convert
so it feels so good to finally win and
with black faces and how did you uh get
ready for this event because we know you
haven't been that active but you always
come and you show or at least try to
show your best here at the U.S
championship
yeah so clearly I didn't prep well
enough but in the last two two and a
half months I've been studying chess
just by myself I don't have a coach or
anything and I took my time off of
everything else of the all the other
projects and even social media so even
social media cut off every distraction I
like that now take us through uh today's
game right so today she played uh
Advanced Carol and um she didn't expect
H5 because I used to play H6 before
um but uh yeah I switched to H5 and
didn't really remember this line to be
honest um
when I checked her game she had played
Bishop D3 and Bishop G5 not C4
but yeah
I think I got a comfortable position and
at least this is a familiar opening to
me I've played it dozens of times so I
felt comfortable and I knew the ideas
uh then she gave me pawn on H4 and I
don't think it was a good sacrifice
because I couldn't see any decent
conversation for her this one on H4 at
this point
Bishop to E3 did this move surprise you
yeah absolutely I expected Bishop E7 97
and maybe Rook C1 okay yes yes I will
Castle short and
it's probably equal maybe slightly
better for white but
yeah I was I was fine with this position
very symmetrical you have some Knight
coming to F5 it looks pretty decent for
you right
Bishop to E3 and just gave you a pawn
yeah I think she didn't want to get kind
of equal position so she wanted to go
all in maybe
um but I really don't see the
conversation and then she gave me
another Pawn on B4 and after that I was
pretty confident that I was winning this
before you have two pawns you cannot
Castle on the queen side you cannot
Castle on the king side but you don't
have to exactly my King's fine on the
eighth only ate very nice uh Nazi
congratulations a big victory for you
and I'm sure we're going to see uh more
brilliant just from you in the upcoming
games I hope so thank you
indeed uh congratulations uh to you
congratulations I just wanted to say
that Megan looks like she's just winning
now like completely completely and I was
really really shocked uh because
Jennifer God an unexpected moment right
here where she could have gone for
um a fortress type of position where she
puts her Knight on B4 and once the night
gets to B4 it really reduces the value
of the majority that white has you put
your knight on D4 and Away you go
instead she played this really I want to
just say shockingly poor decision of
King f8 Bishop C6 and allowed uh Megan
to put her uh majority in to work the
move B4 and that is all downhill from
there for Jennifer as we catch up to the
position Megan
is a passer on the a file another one is
coming on the f file I'm expecting
Knight D6 what else F6 and then
unfortunately this Knight is Tethered or
frozen to controlling uh to protecting
against that pawn promotion the king is
frozen to the a pawn and in the
meanwhile uh White can actually just
pick up all of these poems so Jennifer
really uh even from her body posture a
time ago really knows that it's over I
mean Knight D6 F6 there's nothing she
can do and she's going to see her lead
or her co-lead slip away by the way
Arena Crush are already drawing right
she did she has a drawn here yes so
Arena will be at five and Megan thinks
this Victory will join her exactly so
and Jennifer you will die for the second
place most probably
what a well not disaster but what a big
Miss by Irina in that one yes that one
move H5 could have changed the whole
scenario exactly exactly I'm sure she
will come back home and she will be
really shocked when she will see this H5
and of course she's capable to find such
moves easily just probably she was kind
of obsessed with this idea how to push
this safety on us sometimes you play
something first again it came this
mistake after a long game and again you
have to make all these decisions very
hard so probably she just simply forgot
that she could create this Checkmate net
around the king indeed that's a I'm sure
you're absolutely right you know you've
got this past apron let's just go for it
we know this yes in the Queen's ending
we want just to promote the extra phone
exactly by the way uh
uh I'm I'm looking at the game between
the two Sams and after this move Queen
uh B7 very nicely timed by Sam Shanklin
and I think that it thanks to this move
uh especially that's the move that will
secure a draw in so it's still unclear
who's the best Sam
so this question will remain we will
remain until uh
until they cross swords again
um but as we keep an eye on the Megan
game against Jennifer uh you uh well
we're gonna just take a break and we'll
be we'll be hanging around in studio see
on the other side of the break
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States
the St Louis chess campus in the heart
of the vibrant Central West End has
established itself as a premier Global
destination for chess and is comprised
of two unique non-profit institutions
the chess club and Scholastic Center of
St Louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the U.S
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand Masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of Chess to
Children throughout the St Louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing Scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 Schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the World Chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the U.S and World Chess Halls
of Fame Cutting Edge exhibitions feature
rare historic chess artifacts paired
with world-class art Innovative
programming explores the intersection of
Chess art and culture
visitors can enjoy interactive programs
designed around the exhibitions and
monthly music in the galleries the World
Chess Hall of Fame is nothing you expect
and everything you love three different
Galleries and a premier gift shop
highlight the culture history and
creativity Behind The Game come visit
play chess leave enriched to learn more
about the St Louis chess campus visit
stlchesscampus.org
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to round seven and actually
we have a big result uh Jennifer you
just resigned she lost the game against
Megan Lee yeah we saw that in real time
we knew it was going to happen but still
uh it's quite a stunner here in round
seven as Jennifer you first half those
four wins and she was flying only to
have one loss but then suddenly at this
loss today this one really really hurts
she gets knocked out of first place
Megan says please Irina shall we have a
sharing of the lead and our
congratulations to Megan which leaves us
with Alice Lee versus Rochelle that's a
queen and pawn ending and oh my goodness
well we could be here for quite a long
while as these Queen endings are
notoriously difficult for both uh the
the superior side as well as the side
who's struggling to save the game
um I believe that the Sams did make the
draw
um Sam sebion got the two queen but it
wasn't enough as a Perpetual in the
final position uh well played game a
very interesting game but a very bloody
round Anastasia I should say exactly so
many decisive games I mean maybe players
are getting tired a little bit we could
see a few mistakes for example of course
this game which finished the first
against the linear Sean lost so quickly
and but also the unexpected result in
Alex Lenderman game where he simply
blinded yes let's say ignore I'm sure
that let's say if it was round one maybe
he wouldn't do such a mistake but when
it's already around seven you're getting
a little bit tired and well for a lot of
uh our audience can get confused as to
why something like that happens and I
have I tell you I've seen it in the uh
World Championship uh
a period of Anatoly karpov he just put a
lot a lot of pressure all the time all
the time opponents collapse Magnus
Carlson today is the modern equivalent
version if you will he just keeps
pressure pressure pressure pressure
now you're so close to a draw and all
you have to do is make the accurate
moves but you can't because you've been
suffering so long and well in these U.S
championships which are so strong it's
very easy
to blunder and let's just refresh our
women's results so far we have I think
results except one for this size of game
sevens exactly right yeah well pardon me
yes so Megan Lee as you could see now
won against Jennifer you uh ashrisa
defeated Sabina and then began defeated
and then Nazi won her first game final
in this tournament against Sophia and
yeah
and again Arena Crush tied with Megan
Lee for first an arena really missed a
golden opportunity uh today I felt uh
Christian oh yes absolutely that move H5
was just screaming to be played and you
actually guys saw it in like a couple of
seconds right yes
we're talking about I'm inspired big
move
I think it was somewhere around here no
no when King was on age three yeah this
was the moment yeah we have to look at
the time okay this is move 30 uh 35 and
actually Irena had 30 minutes on his own
Corner clock so definitely she should
have seen the move H5 it was probably
among her candidate moves right but you
have to make that decision to finally
play it and I'm trying to understand
what she missed my guess is that she
missed this idea came to G7 this makes
all sense Queen takes uh the six check
Queen to F5 and now she probably spotted
Queen to F4 and she was like okay we're
exchanged at Queens I'm actually losing
this position so
but then you have to continue wow you
have G5 but you have this blindness
right because you see or at least in
your calculation the queen is still on
D6 then you forget that you played it on
F4 and there's no more pin and you have
this move a G5 that's what probably
happened uh in uh this situation and
sure maybe tomorrow or whenever we're
going to speak with Arena next we're
going to ask her what was uh the move
that she missed in her calculation in
this one but yes big moment and big Miss
because this could have allowed her to
gain the soul leadership positions and
we know how important uh being in the
sole leadership position is it's like
there is less pressure on your shoulders
right it's up to your competitors to
actually come back and uh pick the pace
and get back to that co-leadership
position so there's not as much pressure
when you're in the leadership position
we know Magnus Carlson loves to uh be in
the leadership position Fabiano also
we've seen how striking the difference
in his play is whenever he's chasing the
pack we've seen that at the candidates
and right now he's being chased he can
extend his lead there's less pressure
definitely when you're the leader
absolutely and let's take a look at the
current standings in the open
um the honors
still has this one point lead he has
five and a half out of seven and the Ray
Robson climbed to second place with
foreign four and a half points thanks to
his victory today Victory yes nice and
then linear Dominguez together with a
great company of Darius Sam and the
Wonder all of them they have four points
on plus one exactly they're chasing the
leaders and Jeffrey Samsung Christopher
you all at 50 defending Champion Wesley
so very unusually at a minus one and we
have our new uh co-leader in studio with
Christian we are indeed with a Megan Lee
Megan first of all congratulations
welcome back to the studio there was a
setback against Anna zatonski but then
you picked yourself back up and our
crucial Victory against the co-leader
going into this round Jenny for you how
did you approach this uh game and are
you aware of Jennifer have you played
with I've never played Jennifer before
the first time so I prepared the scotch
against her which I've never played
before
um which I had some help with from a
good friend for some of the prep and she
played um were you getting inspired by
your game against Nazi pakiza yeah I
think the scotch is a pretty safe
opening to play as white you have a
pretty straightforward plan in the
variation that I played
and then you can easily develop your
pieces and I thought maybe if I Castle
queenside I could get like a and did you
expect this move Bishop to C5 uh yeah
she's played it before so
um cool Knight to B3 Bishop to uh B6 and
by the way you decided against Knight
takes C6 which is one of the main lines
how did you make that decision
actually my friend helped me a really
good friend of mine helped me prep this
line so it's nice to be three months
yeah so I think I was in book until she
played like Knight E5
Knight to E5 all the way
so you anticipated her to block you with
the move A5 like that and now Knight to
E5 this was the moment got it and what
were the plans that you surely were
aware of
um in this position uh I think I have um
either making like a king side break
with my majority or
um I had like this bishop E3 idea
planned
um which I played uh
to trade off like the dark squared
Bishops and I think it's like a little
more uncomfortable for black with her
Knights
to know what to do the nights are a
little bit uncomfortable only five and
E7 and she played this move F5 F4 Knight
G4 this was a critical moment after
Knight to C3 Knight to F6 Rook 21 inch
played this move Bishop to G6 did you
see this move G4 I saw it after I played
directory one
um but I think
because you are definitely aiming at
that move G4 right yeah no I missed that
one but you are still in pole position
to have a nice Advantage how are you
feeling at this point she had only 19
minutes on the clock 50 minutes for you
you built up a very nice advantage on on
the clock and still plenty of moves to
go how are you feeling about your
channel I was feeling pretty confident I
think being able to keep a lot of the
pieces on the board made her spend a lot
of time calculating
um and again I think she's a little
unfamiliar I guess with this variation
as was I so
um I think I was able to build an
advantage on the clock yeah but it also
felt like your moves were much easier
you were just like pushing the pawns
making her life uncomfortable uh Bishop
to F7 G3 Knight to D5 and now Knight to
B5
and now finally you got to this position
what was the next critical moment in
your opinion
um
I think when she had her Quinn on D6 and
she started pushing her C pawn and
d-pawn
um her structure kind of got a little
looser so I was able to break three or
break through yeah
absolutely and
you ended up into this end game which
you nicely converted after that Megan
congratulations uh you're in the
co-leadership position and right now
with only six rounds to go are you
dreaming about the Championships are you
starting to dream I'm still trying to
focus one game at a time yeah I think
there's still a lot of the tournament
left so anything can happen and who are
you playing tomorrow I think I'm playing
ashrida ashrida okay big matchup against
ashrida who is also actually uh surging
right now through the rankings three
games in a row do you have any
experience with ashrita have you played
before I think we've only played once
last year so and she was I think quite
that game so I'll be white this time
it's going to be a big match we'll let
you go get your rest and your
preparation thank you our
congratulations as well they can very
very nicely done as uh takes down a
co-leader and we have some social media
questions on USS are you ready yes let's
do it let's have a look
all right this one is from Jay best oh
one two three Yes actually to the
question addressed to Christian who is
not paying attention right now but so
Christian can we know what your most
memorable wins moments at tournaments
are it's a very very short answer
take us to the Finish Line
gotta get in your shots I'll get back to
you yesterday
gotta get in your shots yes the most
memorable is uh the world youth
championship in 20 2007 uh that's when I
won the World Championship under 16.
after that I won a bunch of open
tournaments the US Open in 2018 that was
a big one and then
um I think another one was 2016 actually
that was a breakthrough for me when I
won a millionaire chess under the 2550
uh bracket but still that was a big
victory for me again uh yeah I guess
those four at some point after I
graduated I was winning at least one uh
big event every year
um obviously since 2019 since I haven't
played I'm I'm not doing that anymore
but hopefully I'll come back I don't
understand what Christian is doing here
with so many successes
the millionaire that was a really nice
yeah I love that nice Victory how much
money did you win it's not only about
points
that was that was actually my biggest uh
Financial uh win as well so that allowed
me to kind of you know continue playing
chess and focusing on playing chess I
think it was uh twelve thousand dollars
okay yes and unfortunately this was the
third year of the millionaire when the
price is decreased it was a millionaire
but it wasn't actually a Millionaire
right there there was no uh TV
unfortunately I I know Silverback I
think did the first edition the first
one in Las Vegas which was a lot of fun
we had a lot of fun in that one and it's
unfortunate that that tournament did not
continue I really enjoyed playing that
one hopefully Maurice maybe will get it
back on track but also I mean it is very
nice the career wins and things like
that but for me also the fact that you
were on the world championship team with
uh Fabi of course that was a high line
and enjoying you know rooster and Favi
and getting a linear getting to work at
a world champion I mean that it's a
special ad sphere the world championship
match it's not a victory but I would say
that probably that is one of my career
highlights yes not as a competitor but
more like as a coach yes and exactly any
other as a coach anybody wants have any
of you won any uh national championships
as a coach sure plenty uh more recently
I think is Gregory Oparin uh Gregory
Apartments qualification to the Grand
Prix yes
to third position in the grand Swiss so
that was a big one he actually won like
forty thousand dollars he won way more
money than I did in one event so as a
coach that was a big one yeah yeah great
I was actually wondering who is uh in
Gregory during this Grand Prix events he
played in feeder so wow great job very
much so well done as again we have one
single game remaining Alice Lee versus
Rochelle Ellis the 12 year old
struggling uh to to
save the game The Loneliest people in
the playing Hall along with the Arbiters
actually it's funny we have more
Arbiters now than players exactly I see
three uh Arbiters two players uh it's
you know I look let's be friends I mean
the the tournament Hall is beautiful the
players the the pieces fantastic the
sets the boards everything's really
really nice but my goodness when you're
playing in a big Hall with audiences
it's just such a totally different
experience I love uh well the world
championship matches where you do have a
big audience you just kind of feel the
tension of the audience too
not in all World Championships we had
the audience I think but most of the
times yes and there is a uh the glass
between the audience and the players
that happened in Dubai we had this class
but but I remember in the Vivo where
hobby find played against
yes and then later on nobody could enter
the plane hall and then we had also half
an hour delay so nobody knew what's
happening you know with the game
um and then the players would come for
the press conference and again they had
to show us what actually took place
and uh one more uh social media question
let's see what it is this one is from
Donald Stephen okay good question will
you also ever play another U.S
Championship
um let's just say for the moment I have
no such Ambitions but I must say that
I'm uh my my colleague Alexander
shabalov and I are
sharing a home here in St Louis so he's
sitting there telling me all of these
wonderful stories about the senior uh
Team Championships and how much fun the
seniors are having and this is really
making it sound really good and it's
like yeah sir you would make a fine
Edition you know so these senior
championships and seeing all of the
chess Legends yes I can use that term uh
here in America they're inspiring
they're inspiring but really I once
again I just boldly say the obvious that
sitting here with yourselves enjoying
the Thrills and Spills of the
competitors
makes me happy where I am now on the
other hand what makes me really unhappy
is when you have to study these really
really in-depth openings can you imagine
playing the Berlin like somebody says to
you you have to play the Berlin and
you've got to spend the next two months
studying all the nuances
your inspiration yes so on the other
hand let me interrupt myself on the
other hand a fish a random event
because then you don't have to do any
preparation you just have to exercise
your tactics and your end game so Fisher
random might inspire me to return
okay let's check one more question uh
this one is from dagger yeah okay this
is a nice one actually has yesterday
ever been Furious during the chest match
he's one of the most positive testing
most and I wonder if his emotions ever
got the best of him
[Applause]
yeah doesn't have to be his own match
that's an interesting yes
one time I kind of lost emotional no
yeah
it was it was pretty pretty bad it was
probably singularly speaking is maybe
the worst experience I ever had of a
chessboard So what had happened was in
1986 I played as um Olympiad uh the US
versus USSR and on board one I beaten
Gary Kasparov in the US beat this
incredible Soviet team and in fact we
were going into the last round with the
lead we were in gold medal position over
the Soviets then the next year well the
next Olympiad in 88 Thessaloniki I think
that Gary just had an enormous amount of
pressure on his shoulders and somehow
that carried over in this match
and as we were playing he began to
really
press pieces but really began to hit the
clock very hard and it was getting more
and more annoying slowly slowly yeah
my tolerance was getting really really
really too much
and then he did something that I've
never seen before or since this was
really amazing
he made a move squished it into the
board and hit the clock with a closed
fist yes but he hit the those days we
had these big big clocks and it
depressed the table
and bounced up well all the pieces fell
over no oh really the pieces fell over
but not just on my board the next two is
Boris Coco versus Anatoly karpov their
pieces fell over too
this was too much for me yeah so what
did you do I got
I was ready to hit him
off people and he immediately sets the
danger sorry yes sir yes sir yes sir
sorry sorry he began putting all the
pieces up my time is ticking yes and I
had like four minutes yes and like I was
so emotionally charged it took like two
minutes for me just to calm down of
course no that's a crazy situation long
story short uh the position was even I
decided to play for a win with less time
instead of making a draw I lost the game
jet streams of profanity
followed me to the hotel it was tough
Gary was just I understood later of
course he was under so much pressure but
it was just bad behavior at that
particular moment that just really threw
me
for a loop Boy was I yes upset yes but I
mean these members do you bring them
to recovered
take another lifetime uh for me to
recover from that one that was pretty
tough and then unfortunately uh my
teammates were also really angry too in
those days we didn't really make these
kinds of complaints to the appeals
committee but a lot of uh my teammates
let's say were of that opinion that we
have to do something yes this was this
was bad behavior yes like you you could
probably complain you could stop for
example the clocks this day and complain
to the Arbiter that my opponent pushed
everything else but I was uh yeah that
was that was aware thank you for the
remix
memory Elaine sorry we haven't paid too
much attention to the actual position
this is the favorite type of end game
for us commentators well it's not whoa
whoa yes
it's a great and take a look at this
actually she did get her last streak in
and her opponent Alice Lee fell for it
really no Queen to F2 yes the nice King
to H1 seems to be holding off uh the
draw quite uh easily comfortably
comfortably exactly you're defending the
pawn on a G3 probably at some point you
have to go F4 you cannot take with the
queen because this end game is actually
losing after King to G6 you get your
opposition but I still have one more
bullet in uh my gun I go G6 you go here
I go here you go the other way I go here
so this is uh losing for white but what
you can do is just simply take back with
the pawn you take this one I go out and
then you're not going to be able to do
much with just the H1 it's probably your
best attempt in the position but you're
not going to get anywhere close because
I'm going to go Queen to E5 next I'm
going to start giving you some checks oh
my it's it's probably a draw now let's
take a look at what happened in the game
she played them of King to H3 but now
she found a Rochelle with the black
pieces found this move Queen to G1
immediately a checkmating threat you
have to address that how do you do it of
course with Queen to C6 or queen to B7
the problem is right now after Queen to
F1 King to H2 Queen to E2 King to G1
you can put the King by the way anywhere
you want the same thing will happen in
the position
F4 is coming yes King to G1 F4 came on
the board GTX F4 and now Queen to G4 and
now you're losing both of your pawns oh
my word exactly you cannot go Queen to
G2 once again that's that losing end
this is the losing end game and right
now you're losing both of your pawns
with Tempo she played King 2 F1 I'm
going to take on F4 then I'm going to
capture on H4 as well
where's the Perpetual there's no
Perpetual I'm going to go King to H6
cover up with the queen and then I'm
going to try to basically push my pawns
and win and that way with the two pawns
real chances right now for Rochelle Wu
in what looked like a seemingly very
easy growish position but obviously made
the last mistake right now and she might
be paying for that one with uh the the
full point wow that King H3 uh these
Queen endings
can be very very tricky the the crazy
part is that
um
in according to the table base these two
pawns G7 and H5 could well be a draw
even though you're two pawns up but I
wouldn't expect either Rochelle or Alice
have spent too much time studying these
Queen and pawn endings where one
player's two pawns up they probably
think in Practical terms if I ever get
that position you know I'll play it and
then I'll I'll win it or but this one is
losing this one is losing why is this
one losing is compared to the ones
no chance I will be able to tell you why
this particular one is winning I mean I
remember that game between Fabiano and
mvo yes you remember that one right nvl
actually had a draw yes uh it was the
same two pawns versus none on no I think
it was at the simple cup was it yes more
recently at the single cup okay and uh I
think even mvl came at some point yeah
of course Victory right yes at the same
field cup and then he said yeah of
course I had no idea that I'm supposed
to actually uh be okay in this position
with this crazy move not actually give a
check but it was some crazy Queen to E7
that was just simply controlling the
best squares in position that's not
possible but not it's impossible right
you you cannot calculate you cannot make
first of all in this position don't play
Jesus yes and then it's a draw yes
continuously yes at least that we know
and in general terms the winning
technique is it to play uh G5 H5 King H5
or should she be leaving at the G7 Pawn
on the Square and just pushing her H
Pawn what is the I mean if you could
articulate uh black it seems like you
want to keep the pawn on G7 yes it's an
interesting but you could potentially go
with G5 as well so put the queen on F6
which controls a lot of the checks then
play the move G5 there's no check on f8
there's no check on h8 okay so after
that especially now that the king is not
in front of the pawn perhaps let's just
push the H Pawn and try to focus on
pushing a DH Pawn I think actually this
is much more difficult if the king stays
on H1
if the white king had been if the white
king stays in front of the pause
with the King already out on E2 I think
this is a much easier conversion
because the king is cut yes and that was
the big difference between this end game
and the end game between mvl and Fabiano
uh mvl's King was in front of the pawns
I think it was on the other side of the
board uh on A8 it was the black king on
A8 and by the way Rochelle took a
different approach she didn't put a
queen on F6 she put her Queen on G6 this
is the current position there is a queen
A4 sighting pardon me yes season four
sighting yeah I was thinking that you
you probably just want to keep your
queen
what she thinks as well yeah as far as
possible as far as possible no no cross
checks but it's interesting what you're
saying you could almost say that a
threat
for Alice is to bring her King closer to
the pawns to try to get to the H1 square
and maybe that was one of the reasons
why maybe the queen on F6 I'd probably
want to play Queen F5 which he did
Rochelle's shoes now this is all I can
comment I got the last two moves I'm
gonna rest on my main commentary yes sir
look I press thing on my Laurels did you
know the worst uh moments for me as a
commentator this was so bad it was it
was good it was a queen and pawn end
game it was from the vikanze and Anish
giri the Dutch champ was playing for
first against Wesley so and Anish was
enjoying an extra pawn it was an empty
playing haul you know 700 competitors
had left and uh the dinner bell was a
long long sounded anyway so there they
were and me too and even the Arbiter was
like killing it and I was trying to
explain this queen and pot end game and
I said I can't do it I turned on the
engine
and the engine immediately said plus 47.
plus 47 but Anish is winning anishmates
made some very reasonable natural move
zero zero zero zero
Wesley made a very reasonable natural
move minus 47. and this went back and
forth for like half an hour before
finally Anish won the game and I had
still no idea why the 47 and the zero
zeros it was absolutely absolutely awful
as a commentator you're you're just
you're you're a leaf in the Wind by the
way Queen E5 check is encouraging
nicely timed by Rochelle as she's
kicking the king even further away okay
so now I understand Queen E5 so now I
think Rochelle's idea is to go Queen E4
keep the king
away and by the way that H Pawn is
beginning to vroom up the board she is
playing it very nicely by the way yes no
checks not even one check
why it cannot give you is it actually
the way how to make one check is now on
liquid Niche five years Queen to A5 was
played so maybe even if I play H4 you
give me this check I go King G8 where is
your next check there are more checks
yeah so maybe H4 H4 looks quite fine the
King goes back to G8 uh I'm you can also
play King agency yeah that was the thing
I I might find myself actually more
inclined to play King H6 to just play
nurse maids to the pawn you know like
just keep the pond uh in front I like
the H4 move she played Queen G4 2014 q1
Queen G4 King E1 and I suppose it's time
once again but now if you do that
actually get closer to my uh to to your
pawns right right
well hold on King F1 H3 though Christian
ah and queen G2 correct yeah and even if
you try to protect you still go Queen G2
and that end game is weird that one is
easy yeah yeah this is nice because the
phone is interesting yeah and you step
in front of the pond that is a nice one
yeah so Queen G4 check King went to H1
H4 is on the board
and now uh it seems like Alice is going
to try to find the next check in the
position where are you going to give the
next check from yeah you cannot even
play Queen CS3 again Queen just three
like really yep
so you cannot put your queen on any of
the first three ranks
because if you put it on the first
Quincy one if you put it on the second
Queen G1 and queen G2 oh that's a skier
if you put it on the third then Queen G3
is coming
on yeah
Queen C5 okay sidestepping any
checks it too but
Queen C5 on the board uh I mean she's
looking just to uh harass as best she
can make checks against Rochelle's uh
King I like the fact that if you put
your queen on on um yeah G3 I'm
defending C7 why is that important well
maybe at such a moment if you were to
give me a check on C2 not saying you
should maybe you should give me a check
on F5 I've got G6
Queen H5 Queen H5 Queen okay
five years yes
uh thank you for that absolutely the boy
that would be that's the disaster
just to show actually how you can simply
let it out yes all your advantage by
playing a couple of inaccurate moves
yeah so she played Queen E4 again H5
actually no it does check
sorry Let me refresh this is yes but now
I get closer to the pawn and isn't this
becoming a bit more difficult King F2
absolutely why did she need that
particular check at that moment that's
not good now it's becoming a bit more
difficult probably still winning but
maybe from like okay I'll tell you
something right now there's only five
moves that win and everything else is a
draw really yeah like G6 is a draw G6 is
a draw yeah Queen B1 he's a well Queen
be one yes well yeah you don't want to
allow the green H5 uh King H6 is a move
I would be inclined to play yeah King H6
is still winning okay that's actually
[Laughter]
but why Queen E4 in this moment I mean
yes it was a better moment you had
already cleaned only for a couple of
moves okay
good Queen E4 yes nice
nice move again I uh I like the shepherd
the the the pawns up the board you know
with the King and usually you're you can
slalom around the pond so that there's
no Perpetual checks as well as you're
making progress with your king and pawn
but I didn't I like what she what
Rochelle had done which was to cut the
king and Chase it away the white king
away from the H1 Square
okay came to H6 she's following your uh
your lead yes sir I wanted to ask you
the same question that our social media
asked uh Christian what were your
memorable moments in your chess career
that just was uh I was I wanted to ask
you yesterday oh no that would be here
for days yes
right right right right I cannot compete
of course with Christians that took a
couple of things I will mentioned that
really stand out yeah like I want wants
a youth Championship under 18. Ukrainian
youth Championship among girls but in
this event believe me everybody played
like Anna music
I don't know everybody was playing even
in this different age categories at that
times you know it was not easy at all
and so it was a real All-Star uh yes
those kind of championships I mean
believe me even you were like older but
these girls I mean they were doing
something crazy and you always knew this
you know teenagers yes so it was not too
easy and then all of them became 2500
players so late a few years later and
then also we the same year we won
European youth championship team
championship and I was in the team
because I was the champion I played on
the first board and if I remember
correct correctly uh Katarina rohanan
played on the second board and she lives
now in U.S and she used to play in U.S
championships after yes so at that times
we played for Ukrainian team and it was
I think good moment you know we got
European the golden medals at that time
yeah so they had this used championships
European championships at that time and
it was nice experience as well
um I will just mention those two
so what you're telling you take your
time so what you're telling me is after
your teenager you went a teenage Hood
you went into a slump
like you achieved some really really
nice you played in the national
championship I played it yes yes but I
didn't play for the team because you
know this team was again 2500 players
you cannot do you couldn't find your way
I mean at that time Katrina like no
Natalia
they were really like professional
players I decided that I also want to
study something and at that time I
started law in the Law Academy from my
age of 17 and then of course I played in
many events and anyway
she blundered a cross check
so when we left King F2 King H6 that was
a winning move Queen D6 Check Yes Queen
G6 Queen F4 check Queen G5 don't play
Queen D6 don't do it Alice she did it
Queen F6 and now you're forced to trade
queens and thanks to the fact that black
is two pawns up it's a simply easily
winning King upon ending whoa that that
last move really really hurt if she had
played for example Queen B8 or even
Queen f8 we would still think about my
greatest results
oh then it means I have to get my queen
all the way there but now I go Queen G3
H3 I think and that's probably good
enough but for Rochelle this was a very
important win because she hasn't had a
good uh tournament so far but that helps
a lot and Alice was doing pretty darn
good coming into today's round as the
players get wandered after the game Our
Fair Play competition rules
but uh Christian
uh first Anastasia at the standings yes
let's check the standings we have up to
seven liters now so Irina crush and
Megan Lee they took over they have they
shared the first place right and then
Jennifer you
um
is on the first position together with
Alice lived and now you can understand
what I'm saying Alice Lee had she won
this game she would have been a type of
first that that loss really hurts and in
the open section and in the open section
we remember that Fabiano caruana has one
point distance from the others with five
and a half points Ray Robson is on the
clear second place very happy with 2700
also rating right now live rating so
linear Dominguez
and also Amanda Lang all of them they
have four points in this shirt and once
again that was uh that went we're under
the radar but our big big big
congratulations to Ray Robson for
breaking the 2700 barrier for the first
time congratulations Ray and Christian
final thoughts very eventful round seven
oh it was Bloody yeah four decisive
results in the open section and I do
believe that four decisive results in
the lady sections in if not five no we
had four decisive results in five
decisive results in fact in the lady
section
that is a brilliant game a brilliant day
of Chess here at the US chess
championships I have to say Fabiano
caruana just surging through the
rankings uh it must suck to be the field
right now because this guy is running
away with the event but Ray Robson 2700
newly minted 2700 in the United States
definitely must be feeling good about
his potential chances as well tomorrow
we will be having a lot of exciting
chess coming your way and we will be
here to call all the action thank you
Christian for the last word on starts
here it's been a great pleasure
wonderful to call the action with you
thank you everyone for sharing your day
be sure to tell your friends where
you're hanging out and join us tomorrow
good night good night
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited